Hello freaks.
The fuck is going on out there on freak world and you're like,
hey man,
I'm not afraid,
but you are.
You really are.
Everybody is.
It's impossible to avoid.
If you think you're not a freak,
you're more likely a freak.
If you think you're a freak,
you're probably normal.
That's probably the truth.
If you like,
I don't fucking fit in,
man.
You're probably normal,
but all you Weirdos who thinks this makes sense.
Oh fuck you.
Fuck you all had a freak.
Yes,
you wore
this episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by
Squarespace.
Listen freaks.
I know you need a website.
Everybody does.
I've been telling my fucking trainer about this shit for weeks.
Like,
oh my God,
I gotta do it,
Dude.
Brian's done a hundred of 'em while we've done the commercials.
It's so fucking easy.
Well,
Squarespace lets you make a real professional looking website and do it so
easily and you don't even have to use your money to try it.
It's a beautiful situation.
What you do is you try to sign up,
you test it,
you enter in your information.
As far as like your name and all that jazz,
but you don't have to enter in your credit card information at all until you
decide that you want to use it.
So try it out.
Create a website and then go.
You know what?
This is fucking easy.
This is incredible.
Bam.
SHAZAMM super slam.
And if you need Squarespace help,
if you need help,
they have offered 24 seven super fast email support.
That's an alive on nine chat support.
Yeah,
you can create really easy websites.
You can use your own images.
You can create an online store in minutes.
You could easily sell music,
digital downloads.
Say if you're a band and you decide,
you know what man,
our band needs a fucking a way to sell our music online.
Do you could do that on Squarespace.
Why are you fucking around while you glued to your couch?
You fucking Lazy Bitch today.
Just for once in your goddamn life.
Do it.
Just get up and be the person that you could be.
Live to your fucking potential.
Go make a fucking website.
You can put together an events calendar,
social media integrations.
You can,
you know,
connect it to Twitter or Facebook,
Tumblr.
It also works on everything.
It works on android phones,
works on Windows,
works on a Mac,
works on different browsers,
which was always the big thing when you had a fucking website,
like some asshole to try to break out like Netscape.
Use Your Shit on Netscape and it comes out.
Boxes is little fucking stacked on top of each other.
By the way,
none of the websites created during the making of this podcast reflect reality.
Tom does not like cock.
He's a happily married man to a woman.
These are just jokes.
His wife is here.
Okay?
We have actual solid that he likes women.
His beard is here.
Don Tom has bud sex in this house.
Um,
and that is online right now.
That's how easy it is to make a website with squares.
This is it.
I'm walking off.
Come on.
So disrespect my brother easy with that.
Uh,
use the code word Joe and the number 10 and you will save 10% 10 for the month
of October.
You will save 10% off.
Your first purchase on new accounts.
Includes monthly and annual plans.
We are very happy with Squarespace.
We'd like them very much and I cannot recommend them enough.
I think it's a really fantastic resource.
If you want to create your own website,
go there,
Code Joe and the number 10 all one word Joe 10 we're also brought to you by
stamps.com stamps.com is a wonderful resource for sending things through the
mail.
Oh my goodness is it's so much better than going to the God damn post office and
making someone way your packages and shit.
Like let's just say you create a website with Squarespace and you could fucking
sell the shit that you make on stamps.com you print up your own us postage.
They provide you with a digital scale.
If you use the offer code,
J r e there's like an old timey microphone up in the upper right hand corner and
click on that and enter in the code word j,
r e and when you do that they'll give you $110 special offer,
which includes $55 of free postage and a free digital scale that you are not
allowed to weigh mushrooms on.
No,
no,
no to suite scale though.
No,
don't you do it and don't try to send that shit through the mails.
Seriously.
If you do,
don't use the postal service.
That's a real crime.
Super Illegal.
What you need to do is hire someone who doesn't speak English and have them walk
that shit.
Therefore,
preferably somebody that just arrived and from an really like safe country like
Germany somewhere like you know you're not there,
you're not going to like red flag a drums guy walking out.
Most gets fostered.
They're like,
this is fine blonde and it's probably just engineering or some shit.
I'm stamps.com use the code word j r e to get your $110 bonus offer.
If you've ever seen any of those death squad,
kitty cat shirts at John John,
John Taylor.
Thomas said,
Brian,
Brian makes you want me to call you John.
John is my real name.
Now I'm reading and talking to the same time.
Those are all sent by this service.
It's so simple.
It's a,
it's what,
what Brian uses.
I've talked to quite a few people that sell things and send them through the
Mail on stamps.com because you know the,
the postman actually comes to your house,
so you give him the packages and your dignity.
Dignity done.
That's what Tommy and Christine's absolutely.
They sponsored her mom's house.
I see this.
It really is good.
You guys sell a lot of shit through your mom's house,
right?
You're like,
you're big on it.
Like what was the one line?
The new one?
The one the the black guy that's yelling.
Like spikes.
Yeah.
Yeah,
the new bikes shirt.
It's so cute watching them work together to like,
you go home and they have like their whole little setup and they,
it's like
they share like,
you know,
turns like that in a minute.
We'll talk about that in a minute because I do want to bring that up because it
is adorable,
adorable.
Anyway,
that's stamps.com the code words,
J r e and use that and get yourself.
You're $110 bonus offer,
excellent product used by both your moms house,
podcast and death squad.tv.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] Dot Com that's o.N n.
I.
T.
If you haven't been to on it in a while.
We don't just have supplements anymore.
It's now,
it's essentially we started,
we started calling the company as human optimization company and this is a human
optimization site.
What we have is not just supplements,
but we also have videos and there's blogs up and inspirational shit that Aubrey
puts up.
We're trying to sell things that we use.
I'm trying to sell the things that I use as far as like strength and
conditioning equipment like kettle bells and battle ropes,
all that stuff.
I use,
uh,
ab wheels and all Chin up bars,
all these things that promote functional strength as well as all the different
healthy supplements and foods,
uh,
that,
that we just,
we're just trying to sell you the best shit possible for increasing human
cognition,
for recovering quicker,
for keeping your body healthy,
for strengthen your immune system.
All of the above.
That's on it.com o n n I t and use the code name Rogan.
You will save 10% off any and all supplements.
Aren't you dirty bitches,
Tom motherfucking so grew up in a row and Christina,
her last name should be [inaudible]
good.
Boom.
Hit The music son Rogan experience.
Uh,
Tom Motherfucker to girl,
Christina motherfucker and Buzzer and a December 31st there's a big desk squad
show at the American comedy company.
Oh snap,
San Diego called California.
And uh,
I know of at least one person who you can't even say his name,
he's going to be there because he's not contractually allowed to,
but he's fucking hilarious.
So that's the least one that you know that you know.
We can't even tell you he was on his fucking shows.
What we're trying to say.
Top secret shit.
It's Halloween.
Might be zombies.
I got my Halloween outfit.
Awesome.
Going to be bright,
bright man.
My hat is a tip.
I'm sorry.
That is a tip.
I know what you're going to be.
I know exactly what you're going to.
That is a tip kid.
You're going to be a dolphin.
Vagina.
It's a dolphin with pubic hair.
This is a mess and this right now and this,
this path of thinking,
communication,
stop.
Oh Brian was going to say is you guys,
when we were talking to commercials,
you guys like are the only couple that I know that where it actually works.
It's why I hate generalizations.
I hate generalizations.
They drive me nuts because you know when someone says,
well you know all these men are angry.
This are all these women are angry that or you know,
this is that and that.
Yeah,
well Comedians,
they can never get along together.
It just doesn't work to creative people to people that think they're funny
together.
It's not going to work and it never does.
It's always like either the girls funnier than the guy or the guy's funny than
the girl and there's always this weird fucking resentment thing.
You guys are the only ones that I know that actually pull it off where you're
both funny and you actually are like you're really best friends on top of being
married.
Like you have this air of,
it's very different than the air of most couples.
You know much different.
Much of that.
I think we enjoy each other like we enjoy each millions of humor.
Legit.
Yeah and I think he's super talented and amazing.
That's the weird thing about it.
You guys see both actually like each other.
It doesn't make any sense.
We support each other trying to figure it out.
I've been trying,
I'm studying guys for years.
I'm like there's something wrong here.
It is fun.
I didn't know what's wrong with them.
I didn't realize it.
And then I a guy,
a guy who's married to a comic or was,
I don't know anymore,
cause I've seen him in awhile,
but he was like,
hey man,
uh,
he saw me at an audition.
He was like,
you get pissed.
Like we,
Christina gets something and you don't get it.
And I go,
he goes,
Oh shit,
have my problem.
And I get super pissed when my wife gets something.
I was like,
wow,
I need to go to a doctor.
But that's a natural reaction with a lot of people that have never thought about
that thinking while a lot of people's thinking just operates on momentum and you
know,
you might say,
oh that guy's an asshole and they might be an asshole.
And all respects because of the way they behave.
But it's the past that get you on a thinking like that that are the real
problem.
Right.
It's like a lot of people when they do asshole was shit while they're doing the
asshole is shit the barely even aware that they're doing it.
You know,
they have something wrong with them.
Whatever it is emotionally,
whatever is an imbalance.
And it just comes out like that,
but a lot of it is just like,
how do you dad,
you get to that,
like how do you think about things like what is your choice that you make?
Like when someone,
if do you feel if you feel guilt or you feel rather,
I'm not guilt,
those jealousy.
If you feel jealousy that because your spouse got something,
if you feel that like you should,
you should repel that.
We should figure out what the fuck is wrong with that and go,
no,
no.
This should be inspiring.
This should be wonderful.
This should be fantastic.
Like you,
whatever it is that's trying to flare up it's ugly green head.
You've got to learn how to suppress that.
Some people never do or explore why the feeling is yes.
Usually when you're jealous of something someone else is doing,
it's because you want that thing and maybe you're not doing what you need to be
doing.
Absolutely.
There's a lot of that for sure,
but I think there's a few elements.
I think there's also just a natural competitive element that a lot of people
have to fight off if they don't realize this person is not your enemy just
because this person is winning,
you know,
this person is not your enemy because they're ahead of you in this race.
That's just inspiration.
That's just a person.
Like if you,
if you decide to create a gang of enemies for everybody,
that's you can do it,
you can do it,
or you can have a gang of friends and just inspire each other.
That's totally possible as well with the same group of people if everybody gets
their shit together.
Yeah.
We were just talking about kind of the atmosphere that you fostered by being
supportive of other comedians and that's actually very rare.
I don't think a lot of people are secure enough,
but it's also indicative of that and it's awesome of we were talking about is
it's indicative of successful truce.
Truly successful people try to make other people inspire other people to be
successful.
In other words,
they're not afraid of,
of bringing people along and trying to encourage their success.
Well,
a lot of people are afraid of losing their gig.
You know,
a lot of people are afraid of someone bumping them out.
But I've got a lot of gigs.
I just keep doing different shit,
you know,
and I,
and if I didn't do any of these things,
I'll find something else to do.
There's a lot of shit out there to do,
man.
Like if you get tripped up on what other people are doing,
you're missing out on your own life.
You got to look at everybody who's doing something awesome and go,
fuck yeah,
that's what you gotta do.
You gotta go.
That can help me.
I see this mother fucker out there humping.
When I find out about a guy like who's like a really hard worker,
like a Daniel Tosh who's like,
you know,
Daniel Tosh is like a super hard worker.
Yeah,
I put it like he and I had this conversation because he got accused of being a
lazy writer during that whole heckler thing.
Someone called him a late,
someone called him lazy because of that whole,
you know that all heckler thing where some woman yelled out a rape has never
funny.
It was wouldn't it be funny?
Five guys raped her right now,
but I described that on stage.
I'm like,
that's actually the move.
That's actually what you would do.
Like if you're a black belt in comedy,
it's the equivalent to the counter to the over committed Kamora the far side arm
bar.
Like if you're doing Jujitsu and the guy tries to commit to a Kamora but he
doesn't have control of his body spin around and take the far side arm bar.
It's a standard move.
If you know Jujitsu,
it's,
it's the black belt move.
This is the black belt move in a comedy club.
If someone says rape has never funny,
like Oh God,
you sanctimonious self righteous fuck head.
I didn't know.
I thought it was hilarious.
How stupid are you?
You're making a statement that's so ridiculous.
A course.
It's never funny,
but it's funny right there because he just made it funny.
It's not the actual rape,
but the use of the word.
Sure.
Then he got accused of being lazy.
That fucking guy is the least lazy person I know.
He pumps it when I go to,
he doesn't go there as much anymore,
but for a long time,
every time I would go to her,
most of the beach,
he used to live really close to the club.
He would come in and I'm saying like if I did five spots in a row there,
he would have fucking five pages of notes and try new jokes.
Every single set.
Yeah.
He's always working moms,
anybody you call that guys away.
But my point was that I see a guy like that and I get totally fired up to work.
I get,
I get fired up to see,
like if I see someone have a new set,
like if a new guy comes in town,
like the Chappelle,
he used to come to the store all the time and he would come and he'd watch them
do like an hour and just eat.
God,
I want to go.
Right.
Yeah.
You know,
I just immediately want to go.
Right?
And that's,
that's a,
that's a super important thing for artists.
You know,
you can really waste a lot of energy on that jealousy thing.
It's super easy to do.
And here's the thing though,
it doesn't just waste time.
It doesn't just waste thinking because it takes away from that time and that
thinking from really good shit you could have been doing,
you could have been busting your ass writing new jokes.
Yeah.
You could have been thinking about how to improve yourself.
You had been reading a book on,
you know,
accepting like a new empowering philosophy in your life.
You could have been doing so many different things.
Yeah.
Instead of like tripping out about somebody else.
But you see it all the time.
He's all like,
it's so,
it's essentially,
you know,
it's,
it's like when you,
when people are like writing like these really critical blogs.
Oh,
that one makes me bananas.
Yeah.
I mean they're essentially doing the same thing.
They're essentially doing the same thing because nobody,
nobody is writing like these super hyper critical blogs.
Nobody in the house.
People like happy and those people successful.
Yeah.
I like these weird that in this weird limbo rush and say none of them.
I said,
I hate generalizations and I mean,
yeah,
I'm a hypocrite.
Well,
it's kind of like,
it's,
it's a little bit of that to exist in like a disproportionate criticism.
Yeah.
But like almost like to go out of your way to like,
you know,
tag a youtube video as you know,
how much you hate it.
You're like,
oh,
it's really not a bad video.
You know,
it's about other things.
Sometimes it is though.
Well,
yeah,
sometimes it's about that big.
Sometimes it is,
but sometimes it's not.
Sometimes it's not the sheer volume of shit that's on the Internet and you lose
your power.
Sound disconnect.
Here we go,
here we go.
The sheer volume of,
of,
of Shit that's on the Internet now.
I've been,
you know,
been writing this bit.
I've been doing this bit on stage lately about the evolution of porn from when I
was a child,
but it's just,
I,
it's hard for me to stop and think about a time where nothing came to you from
the Internet.
Right.
But I live,
I grew up in that time.
Right.
That was how I grew up or your life and yeah,
most of my life.
And so now when I look at it,
it's,
it's just become this normal part of my everyday existence.
But for kids,
I can't imagine growing up with it.
It's so,
it's such a,
Oh,
out of information they get an,
actually,
let's go back to this pornography thing cause we were just talking about that.
Um,
like the stuff that I saw first,
like from the 80s,
like Ron,
Jeremy,
I grew up our Ron Jeremy Full Bush.
Like it was always playful scenarios.
Like here's a fork lift,
let's on it.
Yeah.
And now I feel like it's so aggressive.
And it's,
it doesn't feel consensual and fun as it did in the 70.
[inaudible]
well,
there's still some things and stuff,
but the problem is the aggressive stuff is really popular.
Sales Rep,
it's not the most popular thing,
but it's just,
it's so shocking that you focus on it.
Like you find it,
you go,
Jesus Christ,
like some of these,
I watched this Sasha grey video.
Yeah.
It was just like this blow job,
Gang Bang,
and I was like,
wow,
how does it,
where's a person's head at while all these different guys are just balls deep in
her face,
throat,
fucking fucking.
And she's like telling him how much his ball stinks and ask him if he ever
washes his fucking balls.
Then she spits on his dick and just,
but it's like God damn like this.
That's a totally different thing than one of those 1380s Ron,
Jeremy,
you know,
soft,
softer era porn.
Just good filmmaking right there.
Yeah.
I mean those people back then were fucking,
yeah,
they were,
they were having sex and everything.
It was all that.
But there's,
there's such a difference between that and like this,
this thing they're doing now,
every guys on like 15 pills,
a viagara their dicks or crowbars.
I mean the date they did,
their dicks never go lamp and they just stick it everywhere.
The mouth.
That's what I'm saying.
It doesn't end.
It felt like the Nina heart back then that those women were like,
I love sex on pro sex and let's make these movies.
What do you think that is?
What is,
why is it like that?
Like what do you think,
what was it like or why is it,
why did that become a genre?
Like when it didn't exist initially?
Why is it a genre now?
What does Russian thing,
yeah,
yeah.
Cause it's a part of humanity that needs to be expressed and now it is.
And it's like you said,
there's a bit of a taboo attached maybe.
I don't know.
And Yeah,
I think that draws eyeballs.
A lot of it
does.
It has cha I remember I did a joke about it,
uh,
on my,
thrilled CD about eighties born and then a porn star heard it and wrote to me
from the 80s.
And she was like,
yeah,
when we did porn back then it was like,
we were,
uh,
we were like a fam,
not,
you know,
incestuous,
but like,
it was like,
we all did it and we,
you know,
you were buddies with like the sound guy,
like almost like,
what's that fucking movie?
Um,
the Dirk Diggler Boogie Nights,
right?
Like everybody knew each other and it was like you knew that camp real well and
I think it was probably a lot,
lot fewer people doing it because there's no,
you know,
he released it on film at that point,
you know like yeah.
And then now it's like hold up your,
you know,
handheld camera to shoot a fucking thousand scenes a day and everybody knows you
can put it online and you have,
you got to,
you got to tap into a market.
Right.
So there's different genres and it's all about just creating as much content as
possible and hitting every realm of,
of sexuality that you can't even imagine.
There's not even porn stars anymore if you'd like.
Back in the day everyone
had their porn stars like there Jenna Jamison,
stuff like nowadays there's so many girls doing it because of like,
you know,
cam sites and stuff like that.
That seems like it's just diluted the whole entire waters of and the tube sites
like have been crushing that business.
Yeah.
What I understand,
it's funny because that business is a legit business.
It was making billions of dollars a year.
It was totally legal and yet when the economy collapsed and the Internet came
along and socked porn dry,
like you know,
literally like porns dead.
Like as far as like the,
the amount of money those guys used to make producing it.
I mean these to sell DVDs,
DVDs would sell a lot.
I'm like $50 DVDs.
Right?
There's like expensive.
Yeah.
That,
that business is still,
he's still exists to a certain extent,
but a lot of it is evaporated and because it's evaporated,
you know,
it's the businesses,
it's been hit hard,
but nobody ever thinks about bailing out the porn business.
That is the last thing that the government would ever do.
Yeah.
I mean if you think about like you're trying to protect the economy and
different businesses or you know,
critical to the economy.
Yes.
Porn might be critical to the economy of Americans.
Definitely.
Definitely Devon.
But why the multiple Dick thing?
Why like,
yeah,
like the,
the aggression and maybe it has something to
do about our,
we were pressing aggression in society.
And is that why it's coming?
Well,
we definitely have doing that,
especially if people don't exercise.
There you go.
We're definitely doing that because we're,
we're moving towards an error where it won't be necessary anymore.
We're aggression won't be necessary anymore.
I really believe that.
I think that that's ultimately what's the reason why people were avoiding the
white,
they're a bore of violence and why they,
the,
the heat,
you know,
all the,
the evil aspects of life like war.
The reason why all that is because I think the,
the human mind as a whole recognizes that it's operating on some really old
ideas that it doesn't need to do anymore.
And eventually we're going to move towards a point where there's some sort of
complete consolidation of the human race as far as like our ability to
communicate with each other and our ability to,
I think we're,
we're moving towards like this,
this time of not doing all that stuff.
I think it's,
it's pretty clear.
I know.
Tell you though.
I mean,
have you,
have you done the Middle East?
No.
No,
I'm not going over there.
I know.
See and that reaction is right.
Yeah.
Cause I've been there like two times and I,
part of me goes,
I hope.
I sure hope the human race gets it together and we can communicate and then you
go.
Some cultures are so incompatible with our western way of being.
Yeah.
Like will we ever be able to,
I think the Internet is going to open all that shit up.
I really do.
I think it's only a matter of time.
I think he can't hold it back for more than a generation or two.
I think eventually it's just going to overwhelm it.
Right.
The places that it's being kind of repressed now will eventually,
yeah,
you can't stop it.
Well,
you know what?
You're not gonna be able to stop the death of religion.
Never.
Not going to stop
is a fundamental need
to want something bigger than yourself to fear death so much that you need that.
Yeah.
I was actually saying no,
he's not going to stop the the death of religion.
It won't exist in the future.
Oh,
right,
right.
You don't agree with it.
Well,
so he's going to be,
I don't know if humans will.
The thing is,
is that humans are fundamentally afraid of,
they're afraid of dying.
Right?
There's the death drive and the sex drive is Freud said.
Yeah.
And I think that humans are so afraid of,
of the unknown of the part we don't know.
And then that's a great comfort and it's existed since we've existed.
Yeah.
It will always exist.
God,
I think that's just the sense of wonder and also the,
the,
the knowledge that we're finite,
you know,
that freaks us out.
That's terrifying.
So in a sense,
I agree with you and definitely the sense of people replace it.
So if it's not going to be God,
then it's going to be like spirituality and yoga.
That's what I am.
That's why my center,
I just feel the oneness of the universe or if you've done mushrooms,
he got,
Oh okay,
this might get real weird.
Yeah.
Cause I think that new age Oprah stuff is replacing traditional religion.
It would be all replaced by mushrooms.
If there were legal,
all those dummies,
you'd be out of business.
Deepak Chopra out of business just from all of them.
Fuck yeah.
The philosophy of the world would change.
We were talking about illegal legal rather.
I think you can,
you get a totally different perspective on religion when you live in an era
where a new religion finds great success.
Yeah.
You get to see like seeing Scientology,
you know,
I wasn't there for like the actual inception of but like seeing how it has
progressed and grown and seeing everybody's views towards it.
You have to imagine that there's a lot of parallels for what,
how you ever,
you view that and if you go back 2000 years and seeing Christianity evolve
absolutely be very similar.
Absolutely.
Except the distribution of information as much as much for it.
Back then it was much more secretive and you know when Constantine and all those
bishops got together and created the New Testament,
you know,
they,
they got to decide,
people got decide what stays and what goes out.
Yeah.
You know,
they got to sign what they put in and say let's just come on.
But it makes you want like when you go,
cause you,
you hear a lot of,
you know,
people obviously be hypercritical of Scientology and you go,
this is absurd.
You know,
you could,
they criticize everything about it and you go,
well if you go back,
you know,
how,
how is your thing more valuable?
Catholic Church tithing,
people are talking about angels and saints,
you know,
and,
and immaculate conception is like,
well we were like,
yeah,
but that's,
we've been doing that for a couple of thousand years.
That's the only argument is that it's way older.
Does a new scholar that claims or a new published work by the scholar there
claims that Jesus was a creation and that uh,
the,
the Romans made him up as a hoax?
Yeah.
He's the author of a book entitled Caesar's Messiah,
the Roman conspiracy to invent Jesus.
It starts at Christianity,
did not begin as a religion,
but was actually a sophisticated government propaganda exercise to pacify
subjects of the Roman Empire has taken.
Jesus is not new.
Apparently in 1844,
Karl Marx famously declared that religion is the opiate of the masses.
History is filled with skeptics,
blah,
blah.
Um,
it's based on,
uh,
what he described as an important really revealing parallels between a first
person account of first century Judea,
which was an ancient Roman province known,
uh,
now a part of Israel and Palestine and the new testament sequence of events,
locations in Jesus' ministry are more or less the same as the sequence of events
and locations of the military campaign of Emperor Titus Flavius as described by
Joseph us.
Josephus at will wrote in a blog on his website.
Is it cool that they were like Josephus?
That would have been your name.
That would have been my name or it would be your name if you live in like
Virginia.
This Josephus Josephus makes the moonshine.
There's Moonshine you can buy at a store,
but that's bullshit ass tech.
You want to get it from Josephus?
We got to use Hecker.
Would you don't use hickory will.
You ain't making good moonshine.
I like a little peach sometime.
Little Peach would pizza,
hardwood,
preach the hardwood tickled and popcorn and Josephus,
we'll get you what you need.
It's all,
who knows whether or not this guy,
but,
but it makes sense.
It makes sense what you're saying that yeah,
we need to see like something like Scientology in our lifetime where you know,
oh,
it's l,
Ron Hubbard the fuck I've lived.
There's photos of 'em.
Very yes.
And then you read the other shit that he wrote and you go,
hold on a minute,
hold on a minute.
This,
wait.
No way anyone can start one of these
dynamics book in the mail.
I ordered it because when I first moved to California,
I was uh,
you know,
watching TV late at night.
Yeah.
You know,
it's like first time living out here and didn't know anybody that size is,
spend a lot of time watching TV.
And now there was an ad for dianetics improved on my Tammy or get some dianetics
approved my fucking life.
I didn't know dianetics Scientology.
So,
uh,
you know,
I buy the book when it comes to my house and I'm like leaf through it a little
bit.
It seems interesting ideas they have.
And then,
and these motherfuckers never stopped trying to get me to join.
Really.
They send you these things in the mail,
they would send you these things in the mail constantly,
like some new thing and some new offer and come down here and get a personality
test.
And d they are like very diligently netlists they're very diligent.
They,
you know,
and someone who,
is this 94 someone who would buy one of those books because I'm trying to get
your shit together.
Those are the type of people that you would really want to target.
You know,
if you want to have a nice group of people that you can control the vulnerable
when you're at your lowest.
Right.
I was in San Diego filming a show and there was a right by where we were
filming.
There was one of those personality tests,
stress tests and the meter.
And I went over there and uh,
I took it,
you know,
the sat down.
It was,
it was interesting because,
um,
I got a nice read from him.
The guy was like in his fifties,
he had no idea who the fuck I was.
Yeah.
So it was perfect.
So,
uh,
I sat down with the guy,
you know,
there wasn't any weirdness,
like,
Hey,
this fear factor coming back.
It was just some old due to it knowing what do you do?
And uh,
I forgot what I told them.
I don't think I told him the truth or I told them a version of the truth.
So I am holding these things.
He's asking me questions about like my childhood.
Like,
did you ever have a cat that died?
Like shit like that.
And I'm like,
this is hilarious.
what happens?
These,
these tubes are telling you what,
what,
what are they telling you?
And he's like a reading that goes through these camps,
their cure holding on the cans.
They're like coffee cans and he's on the other end of them.
There was a wire and it's attached to a machine.
It's supposed to read your stress.
Yeah.
And from that they can sort of give an assessment of,
you know,
and then they prescribed Scientology.
Any grams are some things where I don't understand that scarred from certain
moments of your life.
And then they go back and try to undo the scarring.
Yes.
He told you what was wrong with you though?
Was he like,
here's what I'm just pretty normally so,
so I could do cytology though.
Yeah,
of course.
Assistant.
Well you know,
I think the deal with like Scientology or anything where a lot of successful
people are a part of it though.
Like John Travolta and Tom Cruise,
Tom Cruise especially is very ultra successful movie star and obviously you're a
very driven guy.
So you see him being a part of something like that and you go,
oh well this is obviously doing this guy like a lot of good.
He's super confident and he's like really positive and radiant with his smile.
And you're like,
well at this,
if it works for this guy was so fired up.
Yeah.
I mean if it works for him,
like maybe it's not so bad because you don't see like any Mormons that are like
super ultra pumped fucking Mormon.
They keep that same kind of on the DL.
It's sketchy.
Like when you know that when fuck head was running for president when Romney was
running for president and it came out that not was he just Mormon,
but he was from a sec that broke away from the United States because they wanted
polygamy,
so they set up a compound in Mexico.
Everybody's like,
dude,
that's a wrap that you take care.
Oh 40 and then 47% comment too.
Oh,
right,
right.
But than not going to vote for him anyway.
Yeah.
Those two things were big that you can't,
your dad was born in Mexico.
His Dad was born in Mexico.
That's why his dad could never be president.
That's why he was running for president.
He was born in America's dad is a Mexican,
like from Mexico because of Mormonism,
because they all moved down to Mexico.
They denounce US citizenship.
Wow.
So that he can fucking set up a compound where they could just ball.
Yeah.
Just wanted eight nine why's.
He wanted to not be locked up.
Can I tell you I love that show and you ever seen,
I don't watch it frequently.
What does this do?
The Mormon show,
all the wives,
sister wives.
Oh,
the HBO show.
I don't think it's only right.
Ah,
you miss it.
You're talking about a reality show.
Like,
oh,
it was a reality show because I don't Dunno if you've seen the wives,
but my favorite part of the show is that,
you know,
this guy was like,
this is going to be awesome.
I'm going to get five hot ass chicks,
we're going to be doing orgies.
And they're all so fat and out of shape.
Like their sister peg,
right?
Yeah.
There are the pigs and,
and it's so great cause like it's totally the opposite of what he wanted because
they pump out kids every year.
And of course,
like they know that's what he wanted,
I imagine because you know why?
Because he gets a younger,
a hotter model,
like every five years they allow him to get like a 27 year old balloons.
Right.
Where the chorus is dark,
deep.
Pretty good.
Lookers.
Yeah.
There's other girls are probably poisoning when she sleeps for sure.
I want to keep a fat for sure.
Yeah.
Right.
I think vice,
yeah.
Did,
um,
at least on,
on their youtube channel.
I think they did a profile on a Romney's Mexican past.
Yeah.
And well they definitely did because Shane Smith came on the show and told us
about it.
It was pretty awesome.
What they did was awesome.
Yeah.
Well they're bad ass advices gangster.
They go everywhere there what the journalism world had been needing for a long,
long time.
Yeah.
Like there and you know,
they get a lot of heat,
they get a lot of heat from the New York Times.
You've got to eat a lot of heat from legit journalists that like somehow that
didn't think that their work was up to standard.
Look,
you guys are being silly bitches.
They had introduced a lot of people to a lot of really crazy shit that may,
they may be,
they not,
wouldn't have known about it and they cover everything there informing them the
garbage patch in the middle of Pacific to what's going on in North Korea.
I mean they went to North Korea and fucking with everybody and ate dinner and
they were traveling around in North Korea filming this.
I remember.
It was awesome.
It gives zero fucks.
Yeah.
That Shane Smith is a bad motherfucker.
He goes to Africa and hangs out with the cannibals.
Yeah.
He's hanging out with the Liberian cannibals,
the guys talking to them about eating babies,
how he's killed the innocent children of the enemy and eats their heart,
eat their heart and drink their blood because it makes an invincible general
buck naked.
This guy used to fight naked.
They call them general buck naked.
Whoa.
He's killed thousands of people and he got away with it because he became a
Christian.
So when they became a Christian they absolve him of his crimes.
Wow.
Lucky.
Yeah.
Fascinating to how that works.
Vice was right there,
man.
Right there.
Covered that fascinating shit.
They were and they were in North Korea.
They did an awesome profile in North Korea before Kim Jong Il died.
Yeah.
And like seeing how they got in and like the,
the reality of like being in the capital city in Pyongyang and like the way the
hotel,
like everybody was like basically you felt like they were just being watched.
There were being spied on by everybody and what they were like,
you know,
they brought them the food and he said,
you know what I mean?
Like to,
yeah,
like lay out the red carpet for them.
But it was basically all unedible.
I think he said like it wasn't good stuff and then they took everything away.
Nobody else was eating,
but there's no one else in the restaurant.
No one else.
They pretended it was a restaurant.
Right.
But it wasn't a restaurant.
They just set it up.
They set up where they were going
to cook for them and made it look like a restaurant.
Yeah.
There was no one else there did it?
Look,
we didn't have a good life over here,
the movie studio,
and they were like,
we've done like the Kim Jong Un's directed like 800 video stuff,
but he consulted on 13,000 I mean it was like,
wow,
that's a lot of movies.
He's like,
yeah,
he's amazing.
Consulting 13,000 rupees.
Lisa Ling did ages ago.
It's on Netflix.
I watch that a while back and some guy escaped who worked in the guard tower.
Did you ever see this?
He got out of North Korea and he's like,
the minute I got under a fence,
the guy that he was with got trapped under the fence and died immediately,
was electrocuted to death.
And he goes,
the minute I knew I got out of North Korea,
I knew that I had signed my family's death warrant because now they go after
your family.
They put them in that.
What's that there area?
What is it like?
Yeah.
And he's like,
I just,
I fucked over my entire family.
And then how do you deal with that kind of a guilt?
I don't know.
Yeah,
there's the big argument.
If the United States was really trying to like clean up evil in the world,
that's the spot we hit.
Drama is as their pores.
Fuck they,
we're really trying to liberate.
A lot of them are Ross,
you're right,
it's bad.
They're scared.
Well,
you would have to fucking free these people first of all.
And then you would have to slowly sort of re indoctrinate them to the idea of
freedom.
What they're,
they're,
they're in one of the last great dictatorships and it's 2013 with the Internet
and everything and with your neighbor to the south who used to be connected to
these to be your former countrymen or banging out cell phones and TVs and
fucking massive electronics and cars and constructive things and all you bitches
have your lights out at night because you can't keep your electricity on.
Like if you wanted to see what works and what doesn't work as far as happiness
and a good population,
you need look no further than South Korea,
North Korea.
There's a difference between living in a dictatorship and living in a democracy
and this same country,
the same patch of land.
I mean it's this,
you can't control people.
They don't like it.
It doesn't work.
And it's sort of what we were talking about earlier about like the ideas of
being generous and helping and loving or being a fucking Weirdo.
I was trying to control everything.
It's,
it applies to people,
it applies to governments and applies to everything,
right?
You can't build walls to keep people in and out.
Look what happened in east and West Germany.
Same goes building laws to keep Mexicans out.
It doesn't work well.
It does work.
That's why there's a Mexico and that's why there's the United States.
Here's the question is,
is it a good idea?
It doesn't work totally.
You know what doesn't work 100% of the time,
but it probably works 90% of the time.
You know,
if it was wide open,
they'd probably be no one in Mexico.
That shit would empty out so quick.
It would be,
oh my goodness.
With the quickness son,
the United States,
we'd double in population in a week and a lot of room in the Midwest don't.
Well,
there's people that would
love,
I mean there's parts of Mexico that people love.
You know,
it was a lot of people live in Mexico City.
They love it.
People would come up here and still lives in Mexico.
Yup.
Ken Kuhn.
He loves it.
She loves it.
I would,
I think that we were trying to be like politically forward backfired.
Uh,
the economy though.
People would come here to make money.
You know,
that's why people would come.
Um,
yeah.
One of the economy and also the,
the,
I,
I see both sides of it.
I see the,
the logic in controlling our economy and not allowing people and because it
allows you to maintain at least one area and try to keep it viable.
But the idea that somebody should be locked out just cause they shit out of luck
and were born and some terrible impoverished town in Mexico and that they can't
ever get out of there and come up to where it's awesome.
That seems to me like the only reason why that would exist is because we as
humans think that the,
the idea of managing the whole world is just too daunting a task.
So we have to block it off in little chunks,
apply philosophies in those chunks and then enforce the borders because like
we're not ready to combine.
We're not ready to combine it.
Cause if you're ready to combine the number one thing you gotta do is you've got
to fix the poor spots you have to fix the poorest about.
Don't you feel like one day we'll have it universal citizenship?
It won't be about,
yes.
Maybe.
Is that it'll be passports will be a thing of the past.
It's possible.
We would have to get over a lot of shit though,
and we'd have to like strengthen impoverished areas.
There's gotta be a lot of money and rebuilding shitty neighborhoods,
just like this is a lot of money and rebuilding things.
They blow up in Iraq was going to say,
look at Iraq.
I don't know if it's a success or not.
Just need to get Halbert involved in community centers.
That's a great idea.
If Albert and got involved in community centers,
just rebuild Detroit.
Oh my God,
the contracts should be billions.
The jobs would be intense.
Be Amazing right now.
Yeah,
that'd be amazing.
Flint and Detroit,
I mean,
I don't understand why it's okay to build shit on other parts of the world that
we blow up,
but not build shit that just fell apart on its own over here.
I agree.
We were in Detroit for a,
that Scifi show and we went to Zug island and around that area and wow.
It's depressing.
It's thinking buy a house for $100.
I'm not kidding.
Yeah,
I saw that.
Cause you know,
the government just gave or loaned,
I don't know which one of the two Detroit a lot of money.
Well it needs it.
Yeah.
And they were saying that like,
I mean there's just like little thing but like 40% of light posts,
you know,
don't work in Detroit in the greater metropolitan area.
It makes sense.
Um,
the average response time to a nine one one call is 58 minutes.
Oh my God.
So that means,
you know,
fire ambulance,
oh my God.
A long fucking time.
That's an average for an average.
Right.
And what's really incredible is that town was created basically on the business
that was like one of the best businesses for the United States ever.
The automotive one point in time they were rocking.
My friend Justin was on the sh the podcast and he worked in the Ford factory for
years.
Chrysler factory.
Yeah.
And it was,
you know,
they could,
people could make a good living,
can support a family and they turned out these cars.
Yeah.
But then when a member remember when like,
um,
well they all had the bailout for the auto companies.
The big thing was that I think those guys overextended themselves with the,
like the offers of their benefits because the whole thing was like,
I think it was 20 or 30 years,
I think maybe it was 30 years.
Yeah.
And then you got like full,
you know,
incredible benefits.
And so you had essentially a lot of people that could retire at 50.
Right.
And that's what one of the main things of why,
you know,
so that's why they were losing money because he had to pay these guys
eventually.
I mean,
you know,
the automotive industry became more competitive so they're not as dominant and,
but then yeah,
one of the things that they said was a problem was that you have people who are
essentially entitled to full benefits at 50 years old.
Yeah.
Justin was also saying that there was also jobs where it required you to use to
people.
Those was union contract,
but they didn't really need to use two people.
So you would have like two hour shifts,
like you would come in for two hours and do it and then you can go leave and do
whatever the fuck you want.
And another guy would come in for two hours and you did two shifts a day and you
each to two shifts a day and that's what you got paid for a full job.
And it's just because of the greed of these,
these auto workers,
the unions,
the unions.
Yeah.
And then you know,
it's also the real,
another problem was they made a bunch of Shitty fucking cars and that's not the
auto workers problem.
It's a design problem and the engineer's problems.
But goddamn United States made some terrible cars in the eighties yeah,
I mean they're,
they fucked up everything.
They fucked up the Mustang.
They fucked up the corvette.
They fucked up the Camaro.
They fucked up all the greatest cars that the United States has ever dose.
Yes.
Fucked him all up.
Completely.
Dog Shit.
Late eighties and the early nine they were dog shit.
They were the stupidest looking,
ugliest fucking cars.
It's like they were trying to tank it on purpose.
You can go back in time and you look at a 1969 Mustang fastback.
Look at like a gt 500 from 1969.
Those cars were a masterpiece.
That's the lines on them.
The appeal of them that just uh,
just look at them just like artistically they had this,
this appeal to them and then they tried to make cars more gas friendly because
the gas prices went up because they had the like the fake gas shortage where
they fucked everybody and oh we ran it again.
Psych.
Um,
then they just,
from that point on they all just went to shit.
They couldn't have those big
v eight s anymore cause they only got eight miles a gallon.
So instead they started making these stupid six cylinder Mustang.
So it just looked like dog shit.
And the big thing now is that what,
what gave a big boost,
at least you know,
like to dodge was that they went to a throwback.
It was like these look like the old designs like the Dodge Challenger
merit of the challenges wrap.
The challenger really looks like an old one,
but the Camaro looks like a new car.
I mean it's,
it's like they didn't,
they,
it's kind of a retro hot rod kind of a look to.
It does,
but it's still a new,
it looks bad ass.
They had a new,
uh,
they have a new uh,
Trans-am oh really?
Yeah.
Camaro.
Trans am and uh,
can you still get the Falcon or those z 28
trans am was the Firebird.
Is he 28 and the z 28.
The new Camaro is faster around a racetrack than a,
than a Porsche raise.
We didn't.
When you in the car play in the video,
the sound of it.
Oh my God.
It's
not as good.
I can do it.
Do it.
Terrible.
I appreciate it.
Brian Couch.
I've got Brian Counter.
Whatever reason likes to hear me do animal animal noises.
I was so impressed.
Her dog is impeccable.
The bear,
the bear has is layered noises.
Perfect.
And so is the lip quivering?
Yeah.
I don't know what's wrong with me.
It's really good.
I really don't know what's wrong.
I can only do a few in PR.
I'm not,
I would never say I was an impressionist cause I can't do a lot of impressions.
Like my voice range is not that good,
but if it falls in my range,
I can do it.
Alex Jones,
you do what?
I can do that and you can do a d as well.
I could do it.
[inaudible] do you see those guys are my range three shouty loudy guys.
Very good.
I can do some people but it's,
it has to like,
you know,
you know like you couldn't say,
Hey Justin Bieber.
Yeah.
Did you see that fucking video?
This is the z 28 that's the car.
Yeah.
Jay Leno's car,
Phoenix,
his garage and Burbank.
They took this a,
that's not the z 28 they took this z 28 and they took out everything.
All the navigation.
Radio only has one speaker to let you know that the door goes Ding,
ding,
Ding.
They took out all that shit to make it super light and put it in a 500
horsepower naturally aspirated engine.
He's got denim on denim,
on Jay Leno.
He always has done a on rocks it,
he's not growing up.
He's a towards her last kid.
Listen to this thing.
Parts like Rambo,
carbon,
ceramics and so on.
It's going to be more,
you hear that?
That makes the guys balls tangle.
Yeah.
Not on the public street.
I'm sure.
At least in California that thumbs up
Malbec tanning rhetoric.
That's cause it's you Jason that for the car.
That is a wicked car though.
As far as American cars go,
that car is wicked.
But you think she can.
Let's just that costs.
It's not much as far
as like the kind of performance,
I think it's probably going to be around 60 grand.
Let's find out.
News.
Each one had the,
the bargains are the [inaudible] and the core event.
They have a new corvette now.
It's fucking incredible.
Yes.
The fucking new corvette is crazy.
Oh,
it's amazing.
And the price is pretty amazing what you get.
It's like 60,
68.
I think they had an inner agency.
51.
Yeah.
Well they have to see 28 is a oh,
the sting rays.
The new,
um,
yeah,
the sting rays in new corvette price.
The stingrays incredible.
Have you seen that?
Yeah.
Go to the,
uh,
see if you pull up Matt Farah.
That dude who was on the podcast,
a smoking gun.
There's that look like when I was a kid corvette.
I liked the brand and the car didn't look so cool.
Wow.
Look at that.
Do you have to put a bra on it though?
No,
those are done.
They don't do those anymore.
Why did they do when people have clear blue now is a clear sheet that keeps the
chips.
Oh,
still avoid paint chips.
from rocks.
That's why people wrap their cars.
This thing,
just like you bought in the wheel.
Yeah,
buddy.
The first thing you're struck by how light and nimble this car is.
This,
look at the seats.
You know what?
Each generation in the corvette,
it seems to get a little bit lighter,
a little bit smaller and a little more agile.
And this one really feels like the best one yet.
It's a sick car.
I just loved it.
America's finally figured out how to make cars that don't suck a fat one.
For the longest time they were dog shit.
I got a um,
a Ford Mustang just because I knew that Mustang didn't take money from the
government.
They didn't take a bail out.
So then I was thinking about getting,
I wanted to get some sort of American hot rod,
so I got a,
um,
a gt 500.
That's why I got it.
I got it because of the fact and because it's just,
it's pretty bad ass.
Yeah.
It's uh,
it's,
they've figured out how to make fun cars again.
Yeah.
They figured out a Shelby.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Those things are fun.
That,
that rumble too.
It's very manly.
Yeah.
This is even more manly though,
I think because he is he 28.
I might have a purchase one of these motherfuckers.
I'm saying.
That's what I'm saying.
I want to support the honestly like no bullshit.
I really do want to support American car companies and Megan cars like this.
That's great.
Are they making them in America though?
God,
I hope so.
Volkswagen.
Then I'll them.
No other people's,
we have a lot of foreign.
Volkswagen just went to now in Mexico.
That doesn't seem like German to me.
Don't,
don't we have foreign though?
Plants here for like this?
A Porsche.
Some Porsches in Alabama.
That's a good question.
I don't know BMW in South Carolina.
No,
Honda does.
I don't know.
But I would imagine that other companies who as well,
I think Porsche is in Alabama.
I wonder if that's because it's easier.
Build the cars over
here instead of shipping them,
you know,
like whatever.
It would cost you to ship them.
You could probably make them over here with the same engineering.
It's all robots.
Yeah.
There's a lot of it is right.
It's all automated.
That's,
that also killed a lot of jobs because everything,
a lot of it is automated,
but the precision that you can get an automation,
it's,
you know,
pretty God damn amazing.
Yeah.
We can print out a car pretty soon.
I bet.
You're right.
Dude.
This is no bullshit,
man.
It's going to come.
I think there's gonna come a time where going to the store and buying things,
people are just going to laugh at you.
Oh my God,
you guys just to buy shit that's so stupid.
They're going to be able to just put like,
you're going to have a printer at home and you're gonna keep ingredients in it.
Carbons,
Silica,
this,
that,
the other different various metals.
And then you're gonna say,
you know,
build me a fucking TV bitch.
And you enter in your credits for the,
uh,
the design for the TV and you get a on your iTunes account,
it charges you for the design for the TV.
That's what you pay,
like a design license fee.
And then you have to pay for the,
um,
the materials.
And then I think everything will be like way cheaper except the machine,
the machine's going to be a motherfucker,
but it'd be just like cell phones.
When cell phones first came out and no one had them,
you know,
they were super rare.
And now you go to any place in the world,
people have cell phones.
I was in Brazil and it was in 2003 everyone has a cell phone.
Rarely people have cell phones,
they're everywhere and they used to be like prohibitively expensive for poor
people because they have the backpack thing where you have to put the
little android phones and iPhones and shit.
Car phones.
Oh yeah.
I actually liked that one.
I had one installed in my car and 89 eight nine I would like to have one of
those again,
just the nice,
yeah,
it's nice.
Right in the center console.
It was a cool thing to have.
Like you would be on the phone.
Hello?
I'm driving right now.
Fucking nobody believed it.
Nobody.
But you would have roaming charges everywhere.
Oh my God.
You were only allowed to use it when I had it.
You were only allowed to use it in Boston itself and when I would go outside of
Boston,
I would enter into a roaming area and the roaming areas would be ridiculous.
It would be like,
you know,
a dollar a minute and a dollar 95 a minute or something like that and it was
just a few hours from your house.
Suddenly today you know it got real competitive and today you could go anywhere
and you found works everywhere.
If you go international and you gotta pay rates that are different because they
have to use their service,
but the United States is essentially where the fuck you go.
You are right.
So crazy.
But I was in western Massachusetts is two hours from my house and it was
roaming.
Oh you were,
you were,
you had like a really little area,
like even in Massachusetts you have roving.
Yeah.
What was that bill like?
It was stupid.
It was unbelievable and I had no money back then.
I was like,
Oh God,
yeah,
I didn't,
I didn't have a cell phone until I graduated from college and entered the
workforce.
Like,
just thinking about being
16 years old,
waving goodbye to my dad,
getting into my 87 Chevy Nova and just taking off for the night and my dad not
knowing where I was when I was,
I didn't have a page or nothing.
And I would just,
you know,
come back to in the morning.
Yeah.
I mean,
I was shooting porn.
I was doing h
striven.
Mack,
can you believe that?
That's the thing is you didn't even know this guy's got one
massive
bill gates.
That's a cock blocked video.
Cock bunker.
Dad's a hater smarter than him.
He's got his big stupid phone.
The kids on a little laptop you want,
it's like 1918.
When,
when,
when did they invent and laptops?
Oh my God.
The kid had a laptop in his lap to the typewriter.
I think it was when his word processors.
Remember those labs?
Hewlett Packard.
It was trying to let you know,
geniuses are ahead of the curb.
I've had a cell phone forever.
Like I said,
I got my first one in 89 Haden and then I,
um,
I couldn't afford it after awhile.
So I think I probably got my next one in 93,
92 or 93.
I've got some big stupid Motorola brick.
The brick called it star tech click and I had an extended battery.
The Nino Brown needed that extended battery.
No,
it wasn't that big.
I didn't have that one.
I know what you're talking about.
I had a girlfriend that had one of those breast.
Yeah,
it's brick.
My brick was a flip.
Oh Wow.
My first one flipped.
I never got the full brick.
I still see,
I think the,
uh,
the Motorola Razor,
which came obviously much later.
Yeah,
it was the perfect fucking cell phone.
It really is.
Yeah.
It's awesome.
But Hammer,
it's not good enough.
It's not good.
It's just can't fuck with today.
Right.
It doesn't have a browser.
It's like we don't want just a phone anymore.
We want a phone that does everything.
I can do my banking on this phone.
How crazy is that?
Don't just banking,
I believe,
to me.
Dot.
To anything I want.
I sat my Dvr when I'm on in another country,
you know,
I can go,
oh fuck,
I forgot to tape the fights.
Did you do it?
Does it just records it for me?
That's incredibly,
that's madness.
Uber.
Yeah.
Uber is incredible.
Amazing.
Yeah.
Well just sending videos and pictures to people and Shit.
How fucking long have you used it?
I use it all the time.
Really favorite things ever.
It's great.
Uber or neighbor was just telling us about that.
Yeah,
we're not on that yet.
Duncan called me too.
And have you done this Uber?
I'm in a car right now.
That's cool.
I still talking the other day and he ubered and he doesn't even do the Uberx he
pulled,
he gets like the SUV one that comes up and he just like walked in there like a
pimp.
I like,
it was just,
it's just crazy.
Like in three minutes you can have like a pretty much a black limo pick you up
for
and the tip is built in,
you know,
I tip them extra,
but the tip is built into the,
the thing,
you know,
it's nice.
It's so easy.
You just get in,
get out,
say thanks,
bye.
That's great.
And you've got a limo ride,
don't you review them or something like that.
Yeah,
that's awesome.
Nice car.
Oh yeah.
Yeah it was or not there was an that we use in Manhattan a couple of times cause
SUV.
So we got,
there were nice drivers.
Everybody was cool,
respectable folks.
Last where I went to,
the guy said that he gets a lot of people that that are just ballers like hey I
want to go to Vegas.
And so they'll Uber from La to Vegas but then he has to drive fucking back,
you know,
by himself.
You know somebody the other day went to Salt Lake City cause they didn't have a
car and they wanted to go home.
So he,
he said it was like two $2,500 Uber to swing
plane ticket though.
If you're going FirstClass that might be better.
Definitely better.
Right?
Yeah.
I guess before,
I've done Vegas in a limo before,
but it's a,
it's a long drive.
It is to drive.
I've driven it to four hours.
It's a long drive to do in one day and then go do something real spent desert.
It's also if you get stuck in traffic there,
that's the erode that was designed back when people were driving model t's,
you know,
stupid two lane shitbag road and it's just going through these desolate areas
and broken down and nothing but break lights for hours and the worst.
The weirdest thing is like there is that the first sign of like the casinos that
come up,
I'm talking about,
they're like the crummier ones.
There's cooler.
It's a broken roller coaster.
Probably a great documentary in that if we wanted to make it,
we all want it to just go to that place,
that one spot and
do a show there and bring,
you know,
all roller coasters and shit.
They're
fucking roller coaster.
But I imagine that that would actually be you look,
you meet and Diaz doing a show in a casino there in the middle of nowhere.
That might actually be fun.
We could bring people in there.
Nobody there would be explode.
Expect what's going on.
Yeah,
it would be a fun hangout.
That'd be a fun hangout.
Just call it,
you know,
disaster in the desert or something like that.
Every one of those places has the thing like these slots pay.
That's what it says.
We got the loose,
we've got real loose slots.
Are you going to go into and hope has been doing a tour of really shitty spots
and such a good ideal burger.
Wanted to do that too.
He wanted to do one with me and him go to like the worst places ever.
I'm like,
boy,
I don't know.
It sounds like it sounds novel but it doesn't.
He wouldn't be better to go to like Houston.
Whether it be better to go to like Chicago,
like you guys got to get out of there.
Yeah,
I'm not coming to you.
It's only helping you.
If I come to you
and mommy encouraging this bad behavior,
encouraging you to stay there,
go move to a cool place.
There's some places I get psyched to be back like Chicago,
you know,
I was talking to somebody about Chicago bur we were talking about Chicago might
be like with the most underrated place in the country,
you know,
like as far as like doing stand up there.
Chicago's great.
It's one of the greatest places of all time to do stand up in Schomburg.
The Schomburg.
It's really the Schomburg.
It's more of a suburban thing.
I do the theater,
the Chicago theater and it's in,
you know,
in the city and it's different.
They're,
they're on the ball.
There are some smart fucking people.
I enjoy the Midwest for standup.
I Love Ohio.
Tastic like for some reason the Midwest really gets it and they're down.
Yeah.
I did one of my best specials talking monkey's in space.
I did that in a while.
Does that in Columbus at the southern theater where,
um,
may west worked get out.
Yeah.
And the WC fields and maybe,
yeah.
Well h that's awesome.
Yeah.
That's one of the stars in the background.
Yeah,
yeah.
That looks really,
really good.
Yeah.
Those.
Those people are like,
I always feel like people in like Columbus and people won't like Chicago and
people and Mike Milwaukee,
they're like smart people,
but also they have that Midwest like down to earth thing going on.
There might be in a city,
but there's like a lot of people that are like real good people that are like,
you know this like,
you know when they call that area the heartland,
like the salt of the earth.
There's a lot of morons live out there.
Don't make no mistake about it.
All right?
This is a lot like a lot of the really earth farmy places in this country are
filled with retards.
All right?
We know that,
but they're also filled with a lot of cool fucking paid for sure.
You know,
and just like everywhere you go,
you're not going to get 100% gyms.
Right?
You're just not,
you're just getting,
there's always a trade off.
Fuck.
Yeah.
And those are the ones that are Turd.
They throw off your,
your perceptions.
Like I've had people say,
you know,
Oh man,
and went to La man to this party.
Everybody was so fucking full of themselves,
real full of shit and that place sucks.
Okay.
I believe you 100% but that how there's 20 million people here.
You can't find one,
one party,
one night,
one terrible clunk of humans and you know,
you just got mixed up in the wrong tribe,
son.
The other one been hanging out with us at the end.
Prob.
Yeah,
it is tribes finding your tribe and wherever you are and wherever you are,
people also talk shit about La Times.
They'll be like,
the fuck you're from La.
This place sucks.
And I'm like,
what'd you,
I went out there for like,
you know,
whatever,
three or four days like,
where'd you stay there?
Like Hollywood and Highland.
And I'm like,
did you go anywhere?
They're like,
no,
just right there.
I'm like,
so you hate fucking Hollywood boulevard man?
Like what are you talking about?
That's not indicative of the entire city.
I've been here since [inaudible] 94 and I don't go there.
Come on.
It's horrible.
It's a bad place.
It's like saying,
I was,
one of my friends told me he hated New York and he,
uh,
he,
he was like,
it's the worst fucking city of everyone.
Like,
really?
Where'd you stay?
Wait,
where'd you go?
He's like,
I was in Spanish Harlem.
And I was like,
but like,
where'd you go?
He was like,
no,
I just stayed there.
Like,
I stayed in Spanish Harlem.
I was like,
that's all you saw?
And he was like,
yeah.
I go,
well,
I mean,
that's not,
you can't take in the city just in Spanish Harlem.
You can't take it in that city in a year.
No.
You know,
you will,
you're going to do is get a sense of like,
Whoa,
there's a lot of motherfuckers here spend two weeks in New York just going from
one place.
You know,
that just trying to check off a list of the interesting places from the museums
to the restaurants to going,
going on Broadway,
like New York is so strange that Broadway works there.
Okay.
Right.
Here's a fucking really good reason why those stupid musicals and plays are
everywhere.
They're so dumb.
They're a murderous assaulted,
your attention span.
But New York is so big and so awesome that it can actually support a whole
community of people that pretend to like that stuff and make them millionaires.
Maybe they do like it.
Maybe I'm just an asshole.
Most likely.
I'm just an asshole that Andrew Lloyd Webber Shit.
So soul crushing.
That's so fucking spirit question.
Okay.
It'll literally be like,
I'm lifting the bottom,
she's lifting the bottle,
we're walking down the street.
There's this,
exactly.
I went to see Brian Callahan had a teacher who was a,
a a theater teacher.
And Brian always gets sucked into,
cause he's such a nice guy.
He just gets sucked into going to these things.
They drag them to these things.
There were there,
there was like,
I'm doing a performance.
I would love it if he's like,
I gotta go,
I gotta go.
So this was,
the guy was going to sing show tunes.
And so Brian calls me up,
he goes,
listen to me,
listen to me.
She must come with me.
I'm about to see my inner teacher sing show tunes.
It will be most excellent.
And by the way,
he's going to be very sincere.
So we went and watched this guy saying like these sincere shows like shit and I
hope you have a dream and you really want to drink.
Like that kind of stuff that when you're talking about,
they're almost like,
like doing dialogue but singing.
Yeah.
So it doesn't even make sense.
Why are we singing the song?
It's you guys terrified.
That's why they're saying we're going to get some angry.
He was really good.
I enjoyed it.
Enjoyed it.
I enjoyed it so high.
I was so high.
My feet were barely touching the ground.
Cause all I could think about was the amount of ad space that's in an atom.
An atom is almost entirely made out of space.
And so I was thinking of like while this guy was singing,
I was like,
why do I even feel the ground?
This is all bullshit.
And that's what you were enjoying.
No real.
This is all space.
Why does it feel hard under my feet?
That's what I was thinking about why this is the guy was going was that here you
have a tree.
Yeah.
It was on Hollywood.
It was on Hollywood
boulevard someplace.
I believe it was a nice place,
dude.
I think that,
uh,
that heartland area though,
not just Chicago,
that whole area is underrated for stand up.
Oh yeah.
Across the warming.
You know what's Kinda fucked up is that not a lot of standups came out of
Chicago.
Like if you look at like Houston,
some of the all timers,
Bill Hicks,
Sam Kennison,
you know,
there's a lot of great fucking comics came out of Houston to my two all time
favorites right there.
And so,
you know,
you compare Chicago to Houston.
Chicago was way bigger.
Like,
why doesn't Chicago have a gang of comics?
Look at New York,
the list of Comedians that have come out of,
it's endless.
It's pointless to even start,
look at la pointless.
Steven Starr.
Look at Boston smaller than Chicago by a good margin in the amount of great
comics that came out of Boston.
Staggering Chicago.
You got Larry Reed,
you know your uncle air.
Remember that guy?
No,
no.
He's a funny guy.
Funny Guy,
a Chicago guy.
He was on one of those Rodney Dangerfield,
HBO specialists,
but a lot of Improv guys sketch him.
Prep guys.
That's true.
Maybe that's what it is.
Second city in Chicago,
they're not analytical.
That doesn't make any sense.
The standup is better.
They know it.
You know it.
I know it.
Why wouldn't they do that and stuff?
It's the funniest shit.
If you,
if you want to go see,
if you want to see something really funny,
you go,
you go see a gross.
Then my opinion and the other area,
I always have good time going there,
but I don't know.
I don't know that many.
Well,
actually Minneapolis Swartz and came out of Minneapolis.
Yeah.
He's a super fucking funny guy.
He's hilarious.
I don't know that many other people follow me.
Why do I want to say that?
Mitch Hedberg came at him and he is from Minnesota too.
Yes.
Yeah.
Good one.
He actually recorded one of his CD's at acme,
right,
didn't he?
I don't know if he recorded one that I recorded one there and I'm doing a
special there.
I love mini a special in Minneapolis.
I love Minnesota period.
It's awesome.
It's an awesome up there.
Yeah.
Cold as fuck.
But I'm going right before it gets going.
November 9th,
which is basically once you get into January,
February,
it's fucking
free tickets.
I had to go to that special,
by the way.
Yes you can.
Tom.
Cigarette outcome suite.
Google mooglie come to my special.
I can't,
but I will tell people to go.
What Day is it?
November 9th.
Yeah.
Yeah,
son.
Yeah.
I love,
I mean I picked it because I actually literally have never had a bad time doing
stand up in Minneapolis.
Yeah.
It's that good.
So that's uh,
I'm in,
um,
I'm in Edmonton that night.
I took her in a colder place.
You're in a cold.
Yeah.
With the River Creek.
Edmundson's fun,
fun.
Do you ever go up there?
I've never been there.
I've done Winnipeg,
Calgary,
Toronto,
Vancouver,
Montreal.
Toronto was amazing.
Yeah,
we did a two nights in Toronto.
We did,
we did the Sony Center.
Right.
Then one was,
we did the Sony Center night and then the next night
we did second city.
It was fucking incredible.
Wonderful.
Uncredible and then people couldn't have been nicer.
I like the people that you run into there.
Oh my God.
It's like a weird Utopian city.
Yeah.
They're super nice up there.
Canada is just nicer.
It's w I wonder,
I've wondered many,
many times to try to figure out what it is.
Like why,
why are they nicer?
Um,
well,
I have a friend from Canada,
my friend Shane,
and he claims it's because when you have the kind of have more of a support
system.
Yeah.
Like the government does take more of your money,
but maybe it's because they take care of your health.
They take care of you a bit more.
And he's like,
we don't really have a need to be as competitive.
No guns.
Like I also feel like 20 guns.
Yeah.
But I remember watching the news in Toronto and um,
and it wasn't like that wasn't a big deal.
It was just so matter of fact,
like there was not a lot of sensationalism added to it the way we do.
It wasn't like be afraid,
be afraid,
everything's terabyte.
It was like,
well,
today what happened is,
you know,
blah blah,
blah,
blah blah.
You know what?
Also they don't have a guilty conscience as a country.
Then I out there raping the world.
Yeah.
Maybe they're upset.
They're a part of some of the adventures that we go on right there.
They're like the dude that lives in the town that gets dragged along to now like
the crazy ass hole that organizes the,
the hit on the other village.
That's right.
You know.
Yeah.
They're just,
um,
I dunno.
I think it is less has that less.
You got to,
we're number one.
You've got to fucking,
yeah.
We loved the whole mantra.
If you stopped and thought about all the fucked up shit,
the United States does all the different countries and like how many people must
be like upset at the idea of the United States as a whole,
not its real citizens like you or I who really don't have any part in any of
this stuff.
But somehow they get lumped in on the same team
and we benefit from our,
um,
empire.
Yeah,
that's a problem.
But we are on this team and we benefit from this expansion from this conquering
of other,
yeah.
That's how they keep us invested in it.
Sure.
And that's when you hear like an Ann Coulter,
it's like,
Yay.
So we gotta go to fucking war for oil.
You know,
people get real squirrely when it comes to that stuff.
And I see their point,
I see their point.
If,
you know,
if I looked at the world the way they do,
and I think a lot of people look at the world like there's these people and
these other parts of the world and these people are evil and these people,
uh,
you know,
they hate your,
for your freedom.
They hate the hate.
What you stand for,
you,
their religion is based on hating you and wanting you dead.
I get that.
And all that oil too.
This is a little bit of that though.
So it,
that's convenient that those same dummies are the ones who have the oil.
Yeah.
It's dangerous dummies oils.
So we've got like a hood,
a winky dink.
Huh?
It's,
isn't it funny?
And they're always like,
it's,
their religion is so unreasonable.
You're not even allowed to draw their guy.
If you draw their guy,
they'll fucking kill you.
I wouldn't even say that.
You're not allowed to draw the guy that might get you killed.
So it's like it's all set up so that it's perfectly reasonable for us to go over
there and fuck them up.
Yeah.
It's almost like,
like if you were wanting to play some longterm geopolitical chess longterm,
geopolitical chess means you got to ensure that you're going to have some
enemies to defeat in the future.
You can't keep,
like you can't destroy people and then build up a new empire from scratch.
You got to keep some and enemies active.
You've got to keep them healthy because if you don't have any conflict,
you don't.
You're not in business anymore.
So you empower these countries.
So it's like when the United States,
and this sounds like total hippie info wars nonsense,
but it's a fact.
It's been going on forever.
The United States armed Iraq and it was a bill Hicks joke.
We know they're heavily armed.
How do we know?
We check the receipt?
No,
I mean they,
yeah,
they armed Iraq,
they armed Iran.
They,
they've armed the,
the whole member thing with President Reagan where he got in trouble because
he's sold arms to Iran and then he was,
he had to testify and he said he couldn't remember.
Yeah,
I mean they have been doing it this way.
We provide a lot of arms to a lot of countries there.
Trust masters,
these are warm masters of war,
masters play chess and chess is a longterm game and you don't want to,
if you want to keep a fight going and you want to keep getting money,
you keep extracting money from the society that supports this.
You don't ever like crush your enemies.
That's why they pulled out of Iraq in the first place.
The First Desert Storm,
when we first went in there,
they decided not to take over Iraq.
They just,
they got in,
they crushed the enemy like with almost no resistance.
The only casualties where because of a Scud missile hit barracks and killed like
80 people.
But that was the only people that died.
Like other than that,
it was like a few people died.
A few people,
a lot of people got sick after the fact when they found out that they were using
depleted uranium and people got like some serious radiation sicknesses and
things.
But when they got to Baghdad,
they decided not to take it over.
Like,
yeah,
we'll just get out of here and leave it.
So they left Saddam Hussein to run the country after they crushed him.
And he basically ran it the same way you always ran.
It was crazy sons.
They fed people to dogs.
They were,
you know,
they were savages.
Saveable savages.
But we,
I believe that in the longterm chess game,
it's important to have a boogie man because if we wanted to go in and take Iraq,
like we can't really justify going to war unless something happens.
And the only way something happens is if other people have some kind of power,
you know,
so they always are going to back off a little.
They're always going to let there be just enough enemies out there.
And now that it's not even like country based.
It's like terrorism like back in the Nazi days and the World War II days,
they fucked up.
They had to call them Nazis.
They call Nadine.
If we beat the Nazis now what those fucking Russians,
I don't like the way they're looking at us.
Yes they ran out of enemies but with terrorism you never run out of enemies.
It's really brilliant.
You need that for the sale to know how to do the sale to the public to be like,
you know what we got to do is cause here's the terrorists and they everywhere
you go and do something else and they come with a bunch of different names.
That confusing is fucked there.
Al Qaeda or the Taliban or wear a uniform,
which is the difference.
Is that all kind of part of the Taliban?
They start out with the Taliban and Judy break off until,
I'm not sure.
Molly's faction and I'll tell you,
y'all have no idea how many bases we do have in the Middle East.
I mean,
when I did several hundred in the,
in the,
in,
in Dick rather a hundred more than a hundred different countries.
We're still in Kuwait,
uh,
were in Saudi Arabia and the government,
the government,
they gave me a duplicate passport.
I had two passports,
one of which I had to surrender after I went in and out of Saudi.
It was like a d quite passport to go into Saudi Arabia to perform and then come
immediately.
I mean,
it was,
it,
was it illegal what you're doing?
I don't know.
But your criminal on my show,
no,
but I'm trying to drive an American car to pay taxes go down.
But it was a trip.
I mean,
we're not supposed to be there.
Right.
What is that supposed to though?
No one's supposed to be anywhere.
There's no one's supposed to be controlling the fucking oil either.
Everywhere.
There's no,
no one is supposed to be anywhere though.
The whole idea is ridiculous and I think it's going to break down.
You just can't see it.
Keep going.
I think it's just like everything else.
It's been slowly but surely dissolving around us.
Yeah.
I think,
you know,
as technology increases,
it's our access to each other increases.
There's going to be,
it's going to be way easier to decipher what other people are saying.
You know,
the whole idea about the tower of Babel keep man forever divided by making a
gang of different languages so they can never completely communicate with each
other.
That's all slowly being broken down.
And it's one of the biggest impediments to piece.
It's one of the biggest impediments,
cultural understanding.
Like I love watching shows about other countries about how they eat and what
they do.
Like I love Anthony Bourdain's Charles specially.
Oh yeah,
me too.
I could watch anything that guy does.
He's an awesome dude too.
Um,
and he,
uh,
he goes over to,
he goes over each of the eat cow models and he was there when they slaughtered
it.
They killed the camel in front of them.
My God,
it didn't slaughtered it.
And you know,
and they,
they're all cooking.
They eat it with their hands.
They all,
you know,
it's like,
it's really kind of crazy.
Like can you like,
you never shake hands with your left hand.
Right,
because they don't use toilet paper.
They're her ass assholes left hand and they eat with their right hand.
They shake hands,
the right hand and then you keep your fucking right hand clean bitch cause
you're going to shake my hand and I'm going to eat better.
Not Be wiping your ass with your right hand.
They tell it's really important.
Yeah they have like it makes sense though if you think about the down to
yeah cause I asked this guy once,
it was like,
did you,
do you really use your hand?
And he's like as much cleaner and when you think about it,
he's like you Americans,
you take toilet paper and then you mash the shit against your app.
Like you mash it against you.
It's just disgusting.
He's like me,
I've done my hat and I use mine and then I washed my hand.
I'm like do you,
so it's like what's soap
soap was what makes you smell not like
you,
but then you see them shifting off of the um,
yeah.
So,
yeah,
I was on an oil platform in between Iran and Iraq and the middle of nowhere in
the ocean now.
And it's a mile long platform.
Half American marines,
half Iraqi soldiers,
and were teaching the Iraqi's how to guard their oil.
That's the theory.
And anyways,
the uh,
the Iraqi barracks,
I got to tour them.
Not so nice.
Like those dudes were shitting off the side of the platform and then the fish
that were eating the shit,
they would fish those fish and then eat the fish.
Oh yeah.
A lot of filth.
The fuck Thursday.
No,
that's,
I don't know if that's just negative propaganda.
Oh Man.
Love Thursday.
That's what the Americans say that it's 100% fact.
Yeah.
According to that,
he said he knows that he's been there by crime.
Broke down crying,
flatter bro.
Bro.
Niggas Shady Keegan.
Yeah,
they're nasty though.
Or mattresses were all brown and grody and savage.
Yeah.
I don't give a shit like we do about it because they don't give a shit or they
don't have the money.
Um,
well we were,
we were training them and providing them with supplies.
So at the time they did have access to these things,
like we gave them a bunch of water bottles and we're like,
dude,
just put this,
you know,
and it was all over.
They were throw the water bottles,
it just all over the floor as opposed to like putting them in the refrigerator
that the Americans had provided so
well,
they were probably like really disenchanted,
you know?
I mean their country got conquered.
Everyone they know.
Oh yeah,
I totally agree.
And you're like,
why are you telling me how to do my thing?
Did you ever think about how you would react to just one example of what we do
to another country?
You could see it.
We can see it in the south,
in the north.
Have you ever gone to the south and people call you a Yankee?
I've had people call me Yankees before.
And you're just fucking Yankee.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm worse than a Yankee Dude.
I'm a foreigner.
Like I said,
my family came from other countries.
Yeah,
no,
I wasn't here when your bullshit was going on with those people.
Wait until they see Palicki.
Oh Jesus.
Oh my God.
Well you some ground of new Ju.
Yeah,
totally new kind of Jew.
But I remember this when I was on that oil platform,
they had this thing where I was like operation win hearts and minds.
This is,
this is the craziest thing.
I Rockwell just fuck the army in its mouth.
Yeah.
Oh you die.
So once a week they had ice cream socials with the Iraqis and they would fucking
find a way to get tubs of rocky road ice cream airlifted onto this oil platform.
And then we would,
I would be having ice cream with the Iraqis so that they would see how amazing
our American rocky road.
Isn't everything amazing in America?
Like don't you want this?
Yeah.
Like yeah this is pretty good.
Fuck it.
I'm just going to take back my grandmother getting their head blown off in front
of him.
Right,
right.
I'm defecting.
This is amazing.
It's got chocolate chunks in it.
You don't like that?
Wow.
Does it make you forget about your loss?
Almost everyone.
My family,
but I think it was worth it.
Yeah.
Cause this is Coleen swirl,
right.
Delicious.
That is so hilarious.
I remember your nephew now,
right?
Yeah.
An ice cream.
I need your kids.
You've got rocky road.
It's so hilarious.
Yeah.
Weird fucking thing.
That is what a weird fucking thing it is to just go into another country and
kill everybody and then give them stuff and then we need this.
We need to set up permanently here guys,
after we've killed everybody.
We're going to be here awhile and we don't know.
We don't think you can do this on your own,
even though you did this on your own since like the nine hundreds.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
I'm going to have to have to go.
Okay.
You're,
you're right.
We won't get upset.
Well,
that's the second time that someone has done that to Baghdad.
It's a,
I've been listening to for the past couple of years.
Dan Carlin's hardcore history.
Yeah.
Just about a year.
A year and a half.
Um,
and he has this amazing series about the Mongols.
It's called a,
yeah.
The Mongol invasions.
What do you like Hungarians are,
are you guys one of the Margiela?
Really?
The Mongols fucked all you.
That's why they came in and fucked everybody.
Yes,
but he has this whole piece about them taking over Baghdad and you kind of
understand why the Middle East so fucked up once you hear it.
They killed everybody.
They threw all of the writing into the river.
They said the river ran were black with ink and red with blood.
She killed everybody,
like literally killed everybody.
Like they killed a million people.
I think they would kill people and they would come back two weeks later to see
if anybody was cleaning up the bodies and they kill them.
Jesus sound,
they didn't fuck around.
It's effective.
And there they say that Baghdad never really recovered.
And like the,
essentially in the 1,212 whatever it was,
when kingus Khan did all that crazy shit from then until now,
they've never recovered.
But back then they were the pinnacle of civilization.
They were like scholars and scientists and,
and they,
they were excellent keepers of records.
All that went in the river.
Bitch,
I'm just cut everybody's head off.
And that's it.
Once you're intellectual history is gone.
Yeah,
it's done.
You start from scratch and everyone's dead now,
by the way,
this might be,
yeah.
Uh,
a hippy dippy Doby thought a pot thought,
but I fear that our culture is going that way because of the disappearance of
the bookstore because of the disappearance of book learning,
book reading.
Uh,
because of like the nooks and,
oh,
just download that.
You understand like there's a process when you go into a bookstore and you go
home interested in this topic and you point your finger and you go,
what's that like?
What's that?
I feel like that experience is gone.
Yeah.
I feel like we're totally regressing into idiocracy and it is going that
direction.
Well,
we are,
have always gone to the path of least resistance.
Every person does.
You know,
you have to fight to not do that.
Right.
And the path of least resistance is he just watched TV sitting on the couch.
She can just go order some takeout is just get a pizza delivered.
Let's just,
yeah,
the path of least resistance is not going to the bookstore.
Getting a book,
sitting home,
reading
it,
absorbing it.
Right.
It's now sitting in front of a television.
Yeah.
We just,
we have,
so like going to the supermarket to get your food.
That's another thing that's probably not good.
It's probably be better if everybody grew their own food.
If we had like community gardens and everybody grew their own food and you know,
Indian,
if you don't eat meat,
all you really need is some chickens.
You know,
if you have a bunch of hens,
they don't,
they lay eggs.
You don't have to,
you're not killing a chicken.
Right?
Like those eggs will never become a chicken unless a roosters in the house.
So if the roosters banging them,
then those chickens have the potential to have a baby.
But otherwise it just laying eggs that are free food,
right.
You feed them,
you give them your table scraps,
like vegetables and stuff.
They eat it,
they love it.
You let them run around your yard and pick up your grass.
That's like a smart way to live.
The way we do it.
We're not connected to our fucking food.
And I think that just like being not connected and information,
not reading books anymore and not exploring and learning ideas that was bad for
him.
But I think on the other hand,
there's never been more information available to everybody on your phone,
on a computer.
But I agree with you,
but it's an abridged weird version.
There's something different about reading.
Um,
let's say you want to know what Nisha said.
There's a huge difference between picking up beyond good and evil and reading
that bitch cover to cover and being like,
wow,
there's this and that idea and making connections.
Then going to Wikipedia and being like,
Frederick Nietzsche,
what did that guy say?
God is dead.
Got It.
Onto the next thing.
And you quoted on a message board does seem like a genius,
you know?
Of course there's a huge,
who said that bro?
That's when you throw in,
let's say someone says something and you Google the debunked and then you pick
out a quote from that.
And See,
this goes back to why our relationship works is because I don't let her
smartness upset me.
Right?
Tommy?
I don't know.
No,
I,
I'm,
I'm serious.
I think w what makes it work is that,
you know,
you like your book and then you're reading and uh,
I'll,
I'll actually go,
you know what,
I should read a book.
I use it as inspiration for your reader that yeah,
but I download my books onto my iPad.
I used to now though,
I'm not saying that that's a no,
no,
but I'm saying it is an extension of what we're talking about.
Like you know,
you have good habits that I,
you know,
copy,
I go,
I should read a book because you're reading so many books.
Do you know what I learned from you that you should watch a football?
Football?
No,
I learned how to deal with like white dudes because I kinda know like Tommy,
he's really good at dealing with like white dude America,
like business things.
And I learned from him.
Like I watch him how he does all white dudes.
Yeah,
like the man,
you know what I'm saying?
Like the mass and stuff.
Cause I'm not good at that.
Like you're supposed to get some juice to do that for you.
I totally have them.
Thank you.
Yes,
I have.
I have it marked Jews.
They seem to have a good grip on how to run they business industry.
What's that about?
I think that people,
I think first of all,
I think a lot of Jews are smart.
If you look at the amount of our smart,
yeah.
If you look at the amount of um,
uh,
Nobel prize winners and in science and like there's an and PhDs,
a shitload of them are Jewish from,
uh,
from,
Europe,
European Jews.
It's amazing how many of them.
It's amazing.
So it's like,
it's,
it's a staggering number.
You know,
I think it's just an excellent gene pool as far as intellectual.
Is that why they're so,
it's a good culture to be born into culturally,
like,
you know,
it's a supportive atmosphere.
It's,
it's the,
it's the atmosphere a lot of times of like helping bringing people along,
sparring.
But there's a seclusion neri thing that they have going on a bed.
They kind of exclude everybody else out of their community because you don't,
and just if you looked at it,
I mean I hate to be a Jew lover here,
but if you looked at it in terms of just accomplishments and just,
it makes sense that they would want to keep everybody out.
If you looked at the amount of shit that they've pulled off,
like intellectually,
like the amount of things that the Jewish people have done.
I mean it's really kind of staggering,
especially compared to my more on people we,
my morning people have like Michelangelo,
Leonardo Vinci and everybody else was retarded.
Yeah.
You make cars and a bunch of
souls who uh,
who look like me look like chimp people.
You know,
there are a bunch of chimp people cause suits,
man.
Good tailors.
Yeah.
And my people are the,
the southern people.
My people are not the smart ones who look like Europeans.
My people are the eight black characters.
It looks like a carried bricks up hill.
So when I say that these Jews are so much smarter than a lot of other
nationalities,
it's just a fact.
I mean,
it really is.
If you look at accomplishments,
let's not say they're smarter,
but they're exemplary for sure.
And so if they were that exemplary in that,
that accomplished as a,
as a race,
it makes sense.
They'd be exclusionary.
Yeah.
We want to keep all my dumb genes from fucking their daughter shooting her up
with some live crazy load that's going to create some half smart half fucking
ape kid going to run around on a ruined things to the Jewish school.
He'd be like,
Bro,
I'm not wearing a fucking Yamaka or,
right.
That shit stupid.
My Dad says it's dumb.
It's fuck.
And then I got to put your money.
God wants you to wear a beanie dude.
Seriously,
we've got this genius that just joined our tribe guys.
God will flowers.
God made beehives and he wants you to wear a beanie.
Shut the fuck up.
It also keeps,
if you're that exclusion there,
you get to keep like,
uh,
you know,
outside competition from your businesses.
Yes.
That's awesome.
Nepotism.
Also,
that is also an immigrant practice.
My father is Hungarian and he'd primarily deals with other Hungarians or eastern
European.
Not other tribes,
other tribes.
He's very explicit,
but that's a common immigrant thing to do as well.
The Asians deal with the Asians,
et Cetera,
and somehow know that they've made blow jobs.
Less of a taboo did Jews,
the Jewish girls always enjoyed the blowjobs and much more than the American
girls felt like they were doing a massive favor.
Think that stops when she married him though.
Yes,
that's what I've heard.
Yeah.
That's a wrap.
That's the fucking bait and switch.
Right?
That's a wrap by nagging.
They,
but they like it.
Like when I was in high school,
that was the word.
The word was that Jewish girls give head and they liked it.
Let's do a poll.
They're always freaking or in the sack I think,
but maybe to asses,
but you know,
but they also have that reputation of being naggy and they have the reputation
of not,
you know,
not being a sexual prejudice against Italians.
I also heard that I'm definitely prejudice against Italians.
Yeah.
Are you,
I don't fuck my
fuck my people since the early eighties really.
I learned a long,
long time ago to keep away from my people.
Jewish girls,
savages,
champ people,
the chimp people.
I've only had one girl swinging.
We ever,
she was Italian full blown.
This bitch took a wind up cause she like,
uh,
like a fucking jersey shore kind of bitch.
Long Island,
long island,
which was crazy.
And she's ready to go to war.
Yeah.
I mean I didn't hit her back.
I just grabbed a hold of her.
I'm like,
we don't have to do this.
Let's not,
let's not turn this into a slug fest.
Oh you can't do that.
You can't get a slug fest with a check.
I mean girls came with other girls but,
well you know,
but,
but my point is I've never had a white girl swinging at me other than Italians.
Yeah.
Been very drunk.
Katie remember her?
I was talking to that kid.
He's awesome.
Yeah.
Located,
I was talking to her yesterday and she was reminded me of that time were date
somebody in the audience.
Davey was on on a stage.
David,
the guy that has,
you know the,
he walks funny.
He was cerebral palsy.
Yeah.
Walks funny.
So,
so,
so he uh,
somebody yelled out like,
you're not funny.
Retard to him cheese.
And Katie was waiting.
She was a waitress there at the time and she came up and goes,
did you just say he was retarding with yeah,
and she just punched him and knocked him out.
Knocked him out.
Jesus name.
Well you got to throw that all through the red band filter whether or not she
did.
She heard him.
Oh,
she said,
yeah,
I'll let you go.
She's from Boston and she's like a boss.
She will punch somebody.
Hilarious.
We had some of the funniest times at that store talking to like her and Eleanor.
Eleanor was now finally doing comedy.
I don't know.
Our Kerrigan is fucking hilarious and she's always been hilarious.
Yeah.
Like when she finally started doing comedy,
I was like,
wow,
why didn't you do this a long time ago?
You know,
you are always aware and she's a hack detective.
You know like I would,
I would say like a,
everybody says this guys with funny is he funny and she would go if you like old
stupid premises,
really done.
And then she would like walk off like she,
she knew,
she knew it was bullshit and what was and she knew about dance moves.
Tommy Tommy's word for like what a joke's not really that fun and you're trying
to jazz it up,
give it some dance moves.
I would call an English putting English on the cue ball and make it spin around
for no reason when you have to really work it.
Oh I know.
Believe me in the south you have to do that a little bit.
Do you think so?
Yeah.
I shuck and Jive a lot harder.
I slow it down too.
I slow it down.
I've always had this,
I think it's way harder for a woman to do stand up.
Yeah.
It gets harder to get the attention on stage from men,
men to give you the ball,
you know,
because guys will,
hey,
I'm funnier news bill.
Hi.
It's,
you can't,
you can't have opinions on things.
You certainly can't have opinions on like religion or politics or anything
controversial where you or I could pull off,
you know,
like I don't agree with this guy,
but,
but if a woman like a woman's onstage telling Jesus,
chokes,
very volatile,
fuck yeah,
it's fall time.
But that's why it's so important.
And I think that that's why it's a good thing to do it well.
It's a important,
when they're funny,
like you know,
that's when it's important because when they're not funny,
they should just quit because they're ruining the rest of the whole thing.
Yeah.
I can't say that because a lot of people start off not funny.
Funny.
Yeah,
that's true.
man.
Everybody ever don't you think every guy or every girl faces their own biases
socially before when you go up on stage,
the audience doesn't know who you are.
If you're a black guy,
the assumption is this guy's gone to be the funniest guy on the planet.
Whitey
people do.
I think he says generalized black dude's on stage though.
I think they give them more,
more props.
A lot of times,
yeah.
I kicked two black people.
They don't know what,
I think a lot of black people throughout history have been fantastic
performance.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
If you look at the number of people like all time,
you know,
a number of black people and number of great black entertainers,
especially in stand up in May,
so disproportionate.
Yeah.
Because if you think of like the greatest comics of all time,
you know,
if you had to like do a hiker down,
yeah.
It's,
we're going to be more than 10 that are black,
you know,
I mean,
there's 10% of the population is black.
And if you took the hundred greatest comedians,
probably be like 50 of them be black.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
They're disproportionately funnier.
I mean there's,
I mean,
Eddie Murphy,
Chris Rock,
Richard Pryor,
Bill Cosby,
you know,
those are in the top five all time greats and there's four of them.
They're black.
Dave Chappelle,
five black guys right there.
Bang.
May,
may,
may is very funny.
Jews are funny.
Yeah.
Yup.
And the Jews.
I watched some,
uh,
dude,
see if you can pull this,
cause it's kind of interesting.
Pull this up.
Rare footage of woody Allen doing stand up.
Woody Allen doing standup from 1965 he was funny.
He was young and he was,
you could tell he was perverted.
Tell you that.
Right?
He's always is assessed with a young pussy.
That's always his theme.
And every movie almost,
if you watch them,
it's redemption through young pussy.
Yeah.
I'm age and I never,
she
and it told us,
is that right?
Of course it's real.
Oh,
is that where my dad doesn't drives get young pussy and they bang them and
they're like,
yeah,
yeah.
Redeeming.
Of course.
Look at this.
Watch this.
Yeah.
How old is it?
Does it say all these enterprise d five,
five.
Oh,
that was short.
They never philosophy jokes and shit.
This Guy Museum of art,
which is this fabulous museum,
we've gone,
oh,
it's a young guy.
I used to hang out a lot.
The museum in search of a meaningful social relationships.
So they're used to look for girl.
I saw on the world one.
Uh,
no by Rubens but a real succulent nude.
Uh Huh.
And make it a contrast this to me.
So like animated
emotionally involved with the paint thing,
you know to God how to restrain me.
Right.
The lick.
Some of the oil.
No,
but that's high.
Where is it that I could meet the kind of girl that would pose but that type
picture I had in my neighborhood,
there's an art supply shop that deals in offbeat thing that I read it down there
and I get the name of the artist bottle off the wall.
I called her up and I came on very strong like an artist.
But you know I used a lot of 30 autistic firms like brush
though I was just adorable and we agreed on this price,
you know,
and hung up,
press stop and my and Baret you know,
little Harvey's Bristol Cream on the head
too much.
What I want to be
now related is a knock on my door head standing there,
just this fabulous woman we meet.
Say Shit,
I let her in quickly,
you know,
and I lock the door with my police lock beat.
We'd take off right away cause I don't know much about art,
but I know what I like.
Fuck.
Look at his face.
She took her off everything.
Thank [inaudible] very professional and calls nine began to shake.
That's my thing.
I,
yeah,
all the time.
I not good at those kind of situations or perspiring audibly.
She's standing there in front of me,
majestic.
I took my piece of paper,
like chocolate pencil and I went up to her.
I like got into a little trouble with that because I tried to trace her sure.
Living as I do in a rich neighborhood.
It's,
he's,
it's,
it's fascinating because he is kinkiness oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
By the way,
you,
do you know how racy that was in 1965 on television?
Wow.
Yeah.
I think it was on television.
I mean,
it's being filmed,
whatever it is.
Yeah.
Um,
that,
that's,
what does it say where it was from?
Does it say like a show or anything is weird or is in front of a staircase?
Shitty set did,
didn't know about sets.
Back then.
TV was only 10 years old.
It doesn't say,
but you could,
when you stop and knowing what you know now and you watch that video,
isn't that something?
What a nightmare that must've been for everybody involved.
Oh my God.
God craziness.
Huh?
You're,
you're,
you and your wife get divorced and you are now banging his daughter,
her daughter that used to be your daughter,
and now it's your wife adopted.
You're adopted daughter,
adopted daughter.
It's not as weird who trusts you as a parental figure,
but it's so weird.
I mean,
has it ever been done by a public figure like that before Roman Polanski was
bang,
no,
no.
Nothing like that,
but nothing like that.
No.
Yeah,
he raped a girl.
I mean,
Roman Polanski did a really horrible clinic.
Jerry Lee Lewis.
Yeah.
That's different too.
That's different to this is you're the,
you're the parental figure.
The parental figure is a way more disturbing prospect.
That's the Mo.
The most disturbing.
Yeah,
sure.
That's the one that makes you just unforgivably disturbing.
But the cut the hot can't help with the hot one.
That's what people will say.
Well in the wife,
man,
she seems like she's off the rails.
She seems off the rails banging Sinatra when she was like 15 and her son is not,
her son is not woody Allen's son or sons.
Sinatra son.
Cause that's like confirm though,
right isn't.
No,
it's totally confirmed.
Look at them.
Yeah,
pull up the picture.
Mia Farrow son is Sinatra son.
Wait til you see him.
The you.
All you have to do is look at them and you go,
that is Sinatra.
Did she get hooked up with Sinatra?
Was slinging Dick.
He's out there with the boys.
A dino.
How much did he crush back in the day?
Sinatra.
Whoa.
Easy Open.
He commissioned our fucking do it.
You guys have a list here.
One of the board.
Bang Dead Guy's dead guy.
Everyone dead.
Puerto Rican dead.
Look at him.
Just shut the fuck up.
That is Frank Sinatra's kid.
Period.
There's no woody Allen and do that sexy Bastard Gorges.
Yeah.
How they blocked the director out of their lives.
She,
I wonder why he seems like he's just want to leave them around when your kids,
especially once your kids that came like 1617 Asian flower.
I just want to touch it with like tongue.
I want it to leak.
The oils.
The painting.
Yeah.
He's like in that video of him doing stand up,
he's like,
so relishing in his perversion also seems like really satisfied with themselves.
It's weird.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Oh,
that kid is mia farrow and Frank Sinatra.
I mean that is,
there is no woody Allen and that mother fucker at all.
No,
my last year started his career.
What do y'all started doing comedy?
Like writing as a comedy writer.
He dropped out of college at like the age of 20 he studied philosophy.
Yeah.
And then he became a comedy writer.
Like dudes like him have just been grandfathered into showbiz.
Like I was watching a documentary on Johnny Carson.
Like,
do you realize it?
Carson's been on television since television was invented.
Like in the Midwest.
There was one TV station,
Carson was on that from the time he was like 18 years old.
Right.
Why?
And then he's like,
one day I got a call from NBC and they were like,
do you want a TV show?
What's TV?
Okay.
And he's been on it since the very beginning.
It was on it rather than he's dead now,
I'll be asleep.
But he was a real antisocial piece of shit at home.
Like they totally ignored his wife and kids.
Like he would come home and just sleep on the couch and be like,
fuck off.
Did you hear it?
But he was so friendly out in the real world,
like out in front of the camera.
Do you think that maybe he just was overwhelmed by all the people that see Tom?
He was constantly seeing giant crowds of people and everybody were,
wherever he went,
he was like getting interviewed and people were coming up to them and
that,
and I know that he had a very disapproving mother,
that his mother was like,
well,
he got the tonight show or something.
And his mom was like,
yeah,
big deal.
Like you still suck.
You're still not funny.
So I think there was some of that always wanting mom's approval.
That hamster wheel.
Well,
that's even less reasonable then because when I see people like that,
they know what it's like to have shitty parents.
Right.
Pay attention to their own kids,
like to do for you to perpetrate the same stupid shit that you went through
because you're too dumb to figure out what fucked you up.
But isn't
at the beginning of the show.
How if you're not cognizant of what decisions you're making,
if you don't,
if you don't know how to think,
then you're a full life is in shambles around.
Yeah.
Did you hear about the Johnny Carson's book that just came out and it talks
about him and his ex wife who,
uh,
I guess he was married to this woman that cheated on him with a Frank Gifford.
Uh,
Kathy.
What's her face?
Just the names.
Kathy Lee Gifford.
Hussman.
Yeah,
frank TMZ.
Now what the fuck?
Well,
like Johnny Carson like broken to,
uh,
his house or her house and found all these photos of his wife and him together
and had a gun in his pocket.
And he like,
this is all allegedly though,
right?
There's none of this was like,
no,
this is all this,
all this is all really true.
But how do you know?
Because it like his friends are word there and they're like Ed Mcmahon and stuff
like that.
And so Ed Mcmahon and him all went to a bar later that night and just got
wasted.
And then,
uh,
I guess Johnny Carson took a girl home that night from the bar who?
Johnny Carson.
So yeah,
I don't know,
man,
that sounds like a lot of gossipy nonsense.
May or may or not have happened type shit.
But the guy obviously lived in a different era,
you know,
famous before him being that famous on TV didn't exist and that sort of
intimacy,
what I was going to point out.
You're right,
you're right.
Is it that intimacy of being in front of the camera every night like that for
decades is incredibly unusual.
Yeah.
And so like everywhere he went,
I guarantee you people just wanted to be around him and thought that he was a
part of their family.
Like you're wanting to talk to him and grab him and he's probably like,
leave me the fuck alone.
Sure.
You know Jesus Christ.
And so that's probably when he went home,
he probably had nothing left for his wife and kids.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
Might might've married a cunt and his kids might've been shitheads.
I mean,
I don't know what the fuck happened.
I lost a lot of money.
Yeah,
yeah,
I lost a lot.
Don't put that up front.
And a few white guy list lost a lot of fucking money.
Big Time.
Nine figures.
I think divorce was one of the things that Eddie Murphy talked about on stage
and raw.
Remember that his divorce was so bad that Eddie Murphy talked about it on stage.
You know,
he took some hits,
you know?
And who knows?
Who knows what kind of a woman he married?
Who knows?
She might have been a sweetheart.
I don't know.
I who knows.
Yeah.
We only went on vacation once and dad ignored us and you're like,
oh my God,
here you think,
oh,
he must be so great.
Johnny Carson's your dad and you know,
you just think,
I dunno.
I like
one of the weirdest things.
Must be like be the son of a movie star.
Yeah,
right.
Especially back in those days.
Oh yeah.
I don't know.
Like I saw something about Steve McQueen were honoring Steve Mcqueen.
Steve McQueen son and Steve McQueen sons weren't sunglasses.
They're interviewing him.
He's wearing sunglasses and he's inside,
which is always like,
what are you doing the fuck are you doing like you,
unless you have a medical condition,
one of their sunglasses on.
It was just weird.
You know?
No matter how big a star you are too,
right?
Yeah,
they can.
They just can't.
I don't know why purple and orange.
Well they can definitely pull off wearing sunglasses.
Yeah.
Why?
Why can they do it?
I don't know.
I was saying,
I was just saying they're so strong.
They're so physically
Tommy.
That's actually quite racist to say that.
Yes.
Even though it's true,
I support it 100%.
The foreign,
I back my thought on that.
Like it's also racist implied.
They have big dicks.
It's also racist.
Imply that they like chicken and watermelon.
Yeah.
That's kind of fucked up cause both chicken and watermelon are delicious and
having a big Dick as a good thing.
Awesome.
And so it's been really good at sports and physically strong.
So why is it that it's a problem?
I think the people that really take issue with that are always take,
they're taking issue with the fact that the implication that and that with some
people are getting from that is that that's the only thing that somebody black
is good at or something that you can be impressed with is that there,
you know,
the great entertainer or the big Dick guy or they jumped fucking through the
roof and you go,
no,
that's not true.
That's,
I'm not saying it's the only thing I'm saying.
That's what I enjoy the most about those black guys is that that guy can show it
through the fucking writes the most about,
I'm sure.
Well this is what do I,
what am I getting out of fucking Lebron James?
How much of the,
um,
how much of reality was there to a Jimmy Greek,
Jimmy the Greek got in trouble with saying,
there's,
here's the,
here's the thing,
my argument on that.
What did he say?
Let's tell people what he said.
Jimmy,
the Greek was calling a game and he said,
I think the actual quote was,
look at that little monkey go.
And of course,
I mean,
you said it and you're like,
that is unacceptable.
But there was basically,
people will pull it up,
pull it up.
Jimmy,
the Greek comments that got him fired.
It's on youtube.
Yeah,
it's uh,
apparently,
uh,
all he's dead.
What year did this take place?
This had to have been,
I want to say 1988.
I thought it was earlier.
I thought it was early.
It was an 88.
Yeah.
1988.
And embarrass cvs fire,
the contrite Jimmy,
the Greek.
What was asking questions about Martin Luther King's birthday and the progress
blacks have made in societies?
CBS sports commentator Jimmy,
the Greek Snyder gave his impressions of blacks and coaching in the national
football league.
His answers could raise as much controversy as well as date things by former
Dodgers executive al Campanis last April on ABC's Nightline news program.
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure they're going to have to equalize it for the blacks,
Greeks,
the Jews,
and for everybody.
I mean,
let's make it equal for everybody.
And is it equal or what about the sports?
Well,
they've got everything.
If they take over coaching like everybody wants him to,
there's not going to be anything left for the white people.
I mean,
all the players are black.
the only thing that the whites control is the coaching jobs.
I'm not being derogatory about it,
but that's all that's left there.
So black talent is beautiful.
It's great.
It's out there.
It's,
you know,
the only thing left for the whites is a couple of coaching job and we need to
get more black coaches.
I'm sure.
Right.
With me,
I'm sure that they'll take over that pretty soon too.
It,
there's nothing wrong with that that I'm talking about his end game comment.
Isn't there a,
there's a common,
he got fired for that?
No,
no,
no.
This doesn't seem right.
I think there's another video.
There's an end game.
He's calling a game and there's a guy,
I don't know.
That's what I thought was,
he was saying something about their butts being higher and their legs.
Me being longer.
Remember that I actually know I for me,
I,
you know,
I don't remember it happening.
I remember learning about it and I thought it was the,
in the game comment that got him the most in trouble.
I mean obviously he could have gotten in trouble obviously for what he said
there,
but why would he get in trouble for what he said there?
Well,
I think the implication,
it's not going to do it on Friday afternoon here in Washington.
Musburger his commentary on him getting fired.
That's not it.
Okay.
Um,
because well what that implies,
that's kind of like attached to the idea that like black guys couldn't be
quarterbacks.
Like they could play every other block.
He didn't say that though.
No,
no,
no.
I'm saying,
but the,
it's,
it's I think connected
to the same point of view,
which was that quarterbacks had to be smart and then coaching is,
is thought of as the total.
That's not what he's saying now.
He was saying the black guys are taking over every spot.
They were saying that black eyes are going to be every player and they're
veteran coach over coaching too.
Right.
It said they were eventually going to take over coaching too.
Like he's very specific,
but,
and if they did,
there'd be nothing left for the whites to yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
he's being honest.
look,
it's not saying that white guys can't do it,
but he's saying that the majority of the people,
hey guys,
the majority of the people are going to be black.
That's what he's saying.
That they're dominating.
He's right.
He is right there.
How is that a controversial pubs?
They also said during the slave period,
the slave would breed the big black.
That's not that time.
But what I'm saying is that time right there,
nothing he said was controversial.
That was the thing that was controversial.
And that's what I was going to ask you about when I said,
do you think that what he said has merit that they bred people to be the largest
slaves?
Definitely.
They definitely did that.
Yes.
And I think proven,
I th I think that that definitely happened and I think you definitely see um,
the like results of that in today's population in some way.
There's,
there's no way you can look at some of the African American,
the black population and not actually think that there's some validity to like
super breeding having taken place.
Like there's,
I think there's a disproportionate amount of unbelievably athletic,
huge black athletes.
You think the agents were bred small then,
but it were proportioner.
It's disproportionate England and that's a population that's been bred in,
in,
yeah.
Well what they know for a fact.
Yeah.
Well that's also the weather.
They're dealing with the pasty because there's no sun.
They'd been there for thousands of years and that's a really involved situation.
They,
those people have been there a long ass time
problem with the that slavery thing like are saying that,
you know,
slaves created great athletes is that white people said it before and it was
always a problem.
But then in,
in recent years,
and I think the last person to say it was Michael Johnson,
less prominent black guy to say it,
our former Olympic gold medalist,
he was like,
yeah,
absolutely.
That's a valid point of view to take.
Yeah.
That we have some super athletic gene in some of us.
Well if you were going to own slaves to,
it only makes sense.
People who own dogs do that.
People who own roosters route fighting roosters,
they do that too.
They did the best with the best.
You can do anything.
Yeah.
You can't look at it from like a,
whether it's a humanitarian or politically correct to say you look at it like,
well imagine you're trying to get production out of humans and you're,
you know,
you see one that's really built and strong and you see another and you go,
you too.
You're going to make kids.
Yeah,
sure.
And why wouldn't those genes then be passed on for generations?
Yeah,
for sure.
I mean,
it seems like it makes sense to me.
I don't have proof of it,
but to me too,
Gene's myth must die.
Michael Johnson links African American sprinters to slavery and revisits a
particularly ugly pseudoscience.
Um,
but why is,
why is that so articulately ugly?
As a historian,
I find to be stunning about what he said.
The claim of supremacy of black athletes in track had never seen,
okay.
Had never been discussed openly before.
Actually with his words,
Johnson plunged himself into a century old debate.
It seems to rear its rather ugly head every four years.
Not Ugly.
Just in time for the opening of the sports largest global stage,
Johnson supported his theory with the examples of men's a hundred millimeter
finals in the Beijing Olympics.
Three of the eight finalists came from Jamaica,
including a record breaker.
When are you saying bolt?
Two from Trinidad,
African-americans,
Walter Dick's and doc Patton and Dutch Sprinter Turon De Martina who hails from
cure Curacao rounded out the line.
Racial assumptions don't work easily as simply noting that four years ago,
all eight finalists in the quest to be the world's fastest men likely had
ancestors who were slaves because race is,
well never simple.
What the fuck is that?
But rather works as an embryonic amoebic amoebic identity formation that chink
changes throughout history.
It's a social construction,
deeply entangled with the definitions of class,
gender,
sexuality and so on.
This guy,
whoever wrote this is an intellectual Dodo.
Oh,
it's a woman.
It's a woman.
That's a Dodo statement.
That's a statement where you're just not being honest about something and you're
trying to be massively politically correct.
[inaudible] spite of the preponderance of information
and you don't follow sports.
If you wrote that,
you don't follow it,
you don't know what's going on in major sports.
You think it's a black woman or a white woman who wrote that white woman?
Yeah,
I think so.
Seems Wyclef political.
Incorrect.
Yes.
Just like the white women that gets offended at every for it.
For everybody else.
The show?
Yeah.
Oh,
the righteous and what you said,
isn't that fascinating?
Yes.
They'll say that to you about like whatever.
It could be a Mexican thing.
We got a worse,
of course it is liberal.
Nope.
Let's say that about the Mexican drug lord,
and there'll be a Mexican guy like high fiving unit about,
he's like,
that's just true.
And she's like,
that is not acceptable.
No.
Like white people are the racial police for everybody else.
Right.
You know?
Yeah.
Well there's a lot of white,
I mean,
white guilt is as real as fuck.
Yes it did.
The white guilt is so real and totally the need to get Brownie points from black
people.
It's so cute.
Other fellow progressives,
and I want to say w two what I totally,
I love black approval.
Like when a black person,
Tom and I always talk about good will you feel
when like a black person,
it's like you're really funny.
Like,
Oh my God,
I'm really fun.
Yeah,
but that's not meaning that you,
oh my God.
Distort reality in a form of journalism to try to like,
you know,
like what that woman said in that article.
Like the way she's saying it.
It's like that's such a nonsense statement.
I'm not sure I even understand anything.
I don't even want to rear its ugly head.
First of all saying someone because of slavery is fucking awesome.
Athletics.
Last time I checked being awesome and athletics is really good and there have
been for sure some horrible things that have had like,
like for instance by people.
So sallians if you look at that whole movie,
True Romance,
I mean that was the whole scene where Christopher Walken and uh,
what the fuck is his name?
Uh,
the dad,
goddammit,
I know the Daddy.
He goes,
your gray,
gray grand.
Easy rider.
Yes.
Whose name was Dennis Hopper.
Dennis Hopper.
That whole eggplant discussion.
It's true.
The more raped all the people.
What's this why my people are savages.
It's where they have dark hair.
That's the people's inability to grasp reality and the brutality of shit that's
actually happened.
It's because it's associated with something ugly.
Slavery was an ugly practice for sure.
People are so terrified of it,
right?
People connecting something awesome,
but coming from something ugly with being a part of that ugly thing and that be
accusing someone of being awesome because of that somehow or another diminishes
their accomplishments.
But scientifically and statistically when you're looking at,
again,
one 10th of the population is black,
but 90% of the sprinters are black.
I mean maybe more,
maybe more.
That's one where they just completely dominate.
How many,
how about football players?
The football is probably like 65 to 70%.
That's pretty high.
And basketball,
basketball was probably 85 to 90% boxing.
Boxing is like,
there's Mexicans and there's a few Filipino Russia's couple of Russians.
It was scattered white guy that fucking didn't have a good dad.
Yeah.
Other than that,
yeah,
it's a lot of black people.
I mean it's,
it's a really dumb thing to pretend that that's not the case.
Black people in the United States have stopped playing.
There's a lot less interest in,
in the black culture for playing baseball,
but not in Latin America.
And guess what?
Fucking black Latinos,
incredibly dominant baseball players.
Cause that's the major sports soccer.
And when you look at black of ton of black people that are Brazilian bitch.
Oh my God.
Come on son.
Dominic shit about MMA fighters from Brazil.
There's a shit load of black MMA fighters from Brazil.
Yup.
Excellent.
Even golf.
Yeah.
There's that one.
That one goes pretty good.
Dominates that whole thing.
One guy not doing so good anymore.
Yeah.
He's not as bad.
He's still,
he's still just got crushed by the media.
He's still practice confidence so bad.
We were just talking about the best house like crazy.
That scandal was I did because at the time I was a writer on Chelsea lately,
so it was a windfall.
Yeah.
I was like man,
from the whenever tabloid gods,
but it was so crazy that the guy,
the nerdy golf player was pulling so much pussy.
Yes,
probably.
I think they're men
while they're rich.
Famous.
Yeah.
Those guys are so baller.
The amount of money that those big time pro golfers make,
even a person that is doing well can't relate to the amount of money that tiger
woods,
his made.
Tiger Woods is like made $1 billion off knocking a ball into a hole in the dirt.
Like I don't think anybody can ever understand the appeal of $1 million on a
bimbo.
Yeah.
You know,
a billion off the charts off the charts.
A guy who makes billions knocking ball and just likes to slink Dick.
That's so great.
Yeah.
The way I described it,
I said that he looked like a really unfortunate looking,
but wildly successful man who was attacked by sluts.
If he,
well,
that's for fleas.
He would need a color and I'm so much shaming by.
No,
no,
no.
But just they should just be able to do whatever they want to do.
But just as a story,
it's a bad word.
Made me take it away.
Free Girl.
I feel like post to it.
I don't like it as a woman,
I,
I want,
I want us to be better.
I'd like us to be contributors to our society.
I like us to win Nobel prizes and not take rich guys money for sex.
I just mean for sure.
There's a lot of men out there that have taken someone's money too.
There's gold diggers that are men.
I know gold diggers that are men that have wives that are rich and famous.
They don't do shit.
Not famous rather,
but rich and successful,
I should say.
Yeah,
here's disproportionate,
but weak people,
weak people.
Everywhere you go,
there's always someone who wants someone to take care of them.
This sons of rich men are oftentimes just as bad as a gold digger,
like having no desire to achieve or perform anything,
a delusional perception of reality.
You know,
a delusional idea of what their own value is because they don't really
contribute.
They just were given a free ride,
so they never developed a character.
Unbelievably privileged,
like an really nice free ride where they feel very entitled to everything.
How much,
like when I said,
you know that you can't ever say that comics can't have a successful
relationship because you guys can do it.
You can never say that.
You just,
you can't say that.
There's always going to be a group of people at any gender,
whether it's transgender,
whether it's gay.
There's always going to be a group of people that just fail.
There's going to be a group of women that fail.
A group of men that fail is going to be people that just don't get their shit
together.
Don't ever self actualize,
don't ever pursue their dreams,
don't ever get involved in anything they truly love.
It's going to happen.
But there's always gonna be people that do.
They're always have bins from Amelia Earhart to,
you know,
fill in the blank.
All throughout history,
there's always been women that have figured out a way to achieve and,
and do things that they really,
truly enjoy doing.
Like our flight attendant
[inaudible]
we are hijacked for the longest time I've ever been hijacked as an adult.
Oh No.
Tommy and I were having a fun little conversation and a,
we ordered a little glass of wine because were gentlemen,
and we're on a business trip.
We decided to have a little wine and we're sitting there,
uh,
and the woman came over and she made a joke about the temperature of the wine
and I made the mistake of going,
um,
is it like you're apologizing?
It's too cold.
That's funny.
I've never heard anybody apologize of wine.
It's too cold.
She goes,
Huh.
Well,
if you remember the scene from sideways.
He,
I've never really been much into one.
The only time I drink wine is in church,
but there's a funny thing about wine.
I knew a guy and the guy was a wine connoisseur and they brought him a bottle of
wine and said,
should we put this in the refrigerator?
You script,
don't you touch it and put it in the refrigerator.
Don't you put a hand on that wine and bringing in voice.
I thought it was so funny,
but of course I don't drink.
The only time I drink it a drunk and he went on and on and on.
Yes,
to the point where I was lucky because I was in the window,
so I just abandoned Tommy.
I lifted up the window and I put my face to the glass and I reached into my
laptop bag,
but I put it up,
pulled out my notepad and I started writing down and I wrote in my note pad.
That flight attendant won't shut the fuck up.
I wrote that in my,
nope.
I started writing it in front of her too.
Yes.
Well,
first of all,
she came out when she came over,
she goes,
do you want something to drink?
I said,
yeah,
um,
do you have peanut and war?
Which is not that crazy to say because sometimes they go,
no,
we have cab won't shut the fuck up.
Yeah.
She just has to be addressed.
When I said,
do you have he know in war?
She goes,
uh,
excuse me.
And I go,
Pinot Noir.
She goes,
do you think you're in Leone,
France?
And I was like,
no,
it's not.
Yeah,
it's not crazy.
And she was like,
we got red or white.
And I was like,
all right,
red.
And then when she came back,
it was sideways.
It was the so Monet at Macy's who when I worked at the hospital,
they brought him the wine and he said,
should I chill this?
We're talking about the most like
boring sentences.
Oh yeah.
These were,
these were incredibly boring sentences.
It's the worst.
Oh God.
When she left,
when she left and we go like,
what the fuck was that?
She left,
she came back and I just made,
I like,
I just looked up.
She goes,
do you ever see the movie?
Simon was like [inaudible] she was like my favorite scene and that has a wine
scene.
And I was like,
all right.
She goes and I,
this is when I zoned out.
She's like Bruce Willis and whatever.
And she was like,
it ain't not all right.
All the wine fall I know was a great scene.
And I was like,
she wouldn't stop.
And you know what's really fascinating before this happened,
before this happened,
Tommy nailed her personality cause we may or may not have had
before we got on that plane.
And so we were uh,
it was just starting to kick in and mid flight and he goes,
you know,
when I think,
I think that they put her on this small plane because she can't work well with
others and that the other students is don't like working with her.
So they stick her on these small planes cause she doesn't,
she doesn't want to be around anybody.
She's probably been doing this a long time and they know she doesn't work well
with others.
And then she came over and just right away gave us the ferocious ear beading,
right?
Yes.
It was an ear beating was also,
she gave us an ear beating on church,
shutting off the phones to like everything else up her phone,
pressing this button and we didn't have our phones on.
It's not like we were resisting,
we shut our phones off,
but she did it for the whole thing.
Like this is what I want you to do,
right?
You see this button,
I want you to press this button,
not in airplane mode folks,
not in airplane mode.
I want you to shut this button.
If you have an iPhone,
I want you to slide that over the to shut it off.
And I mean she's going on and on and on it taking a long ass time.
And if you wanted to read a book or if you wanted to,
you know,
listen to your Ipod,
eh,
that's not happening.
No,
you're dealing with this nonsense you're dealing with and you can't even fight
against that nonsense because if you argue at all about anything,
they kick you off the plane.
Yep.
She's got the Passover.
I had a friend that kicked off the plane because he was upset that they didn't
find a seat for his son next to him.
Like they didn't find anybody that was willing to move.
It was an hour and a half flight from San Francisco to Seattle.
It's a quick ass flight and they,
you know,
he said,
is there,
is it possible?
She was like,
sir,
we've tried.
There's nothing we can do.
He goes,
I have a five year old though.
Like,
why did you guys sell me a ticket?
I told you it was five years old.
You can't have a five year old sit by himself.
He's,
he's terrified of flying in the first place.
Like all I'm asking is someone,
if you ask if someone could switch seats,
and she said,
sir,
I've tried.
There's nothing we can do.
Please take your seat.
And he was like,
you guys are the most unfathomably friendly airline.
Like you guys are horrible.
I can't believe you're doing this.
So that's all he says.
He goes and sits down and the fucking captain comes up to him,
said,
sir,
are you going to have to come off the same?
They say you're aggressive and you're,
he was like,
what?
He goes,
you've got to be,
you must be joking.
He goes,
all I asked is if they could find a seat for my son.
I didn't use profanity.
I didn't raise my voice.
I said,
you guys are the most unfairly friendly airline that I've ever seen.
That's all I said,
because you weren't even willing to like look for someone.
And they kicked him off the plane and he was like,
I can't believe this.
He goes,
I'm not aggressive.
But we saw that was it.
You and I that saw that?
Who did we see?
We on a plane,
we saw two guys arguing about the,
the bin.
Um,
I dunno with me on that one.
I don't think I've seen two people kicked out.
It might've been Ari.
I've seen a lady to get kicked off or having attitude,
um,
about like her whole day.
And she was like,
and then you put me later on this shit.
And now me and him talking about it and she was just complaining,
complaining,
and you know,
she was I think aggressive speaking to them.
Boom,
boom.
And I saw one who got kicked her whole family off and she had small children.
She was breastfeeding one of them.
And they were like,
we're going to taxi now and you need to,
you know,
I watch you get kicked off.
She gave the lady attitude about the flight attendant attitude when the flight
attendant asked her,
um,
I don't know if she asked her to stop breastfeeding while we were going to taxi,
but she told her like,
you know,
why don't you just worry about the drinks while I'm breastfeeding?
And they were like,
ah.
And then we stopped and they actually,
that one,
they had police come out to the,
uh,
to the point,
he even go back.
The police came out of,
they opened the door.
They just get off on the power.
Absolutely.
I think sometimes,
uh,
I think sometimes they,
they absolutely want to protect themselves and they have to,
you know,
you can't have somebody who's a,
an actual threat to the flight.
But I think,
I think there's definitely a thrill and knowing that if somebody gives you kind
of a little jab,
kind of a little attitude,
you can be like,
I could fuck up your day right now.
Yeah.
Pretty,
pretty badly.
And I can justify it.
And we were talking about that,
that this ability to hijack you is kind of the same thing because in a normal
scenario,
you don't have to listen to this person.
You're not stuck in a chair,
literally strapped in with a fucking belt.
Yeah.
You have to listen and then they can just hover over you and just shit in your
face.
Headphones,
Amazon
in your hood and your glasses.
That's why I do that.
In the middle of a conversation when you're having a conversation with another
guy and then you're having a wine and then all of a sudden,
boom,
you're stuck.
The glasses,
I don't know if you remember the glasses where these,
they're like tasting glasses.
They weren't very small,
very small.
And the first time I had two sips in his empty and she goes,
do you want a refill?
And I go,
yeah.
She goes,
oh,
I had a couple of drinkers up here and I was like,
it's Kinda like,
you know,
I can see a certain person,
not me personally,
but I could see that comment really setting somebody off the,
the outside implication of like a couple of drunks.
I don't want to say anyway.
No,
no,
no need to say anymore than we already said.
We already got to cruel.
Poor Lady.
She's lonely.
She wants to talk to people.
Was just crushed a couple of assholes.
That's okay.
That's all I know.
I feel.
I feel it right about it.
It's an inability to read social cues.
Yes.
Oh,
there's no doubt.
She has no doubt.
Zero ability.
She wasn't good at it or she didn't care.
She just wanted to talk.
You know,
who knows?
A lot of people,
by the way,
are a little pilled up and they don't even know that.
You don't want them to talk to you like there's some every
peak,
everything's gonna be okay folks.
Here's a few of those people that are an antidepressant.
The fuck up,
super duper common.
If you look at the number of prescriptions sold,
the number of anti disco,
a antidepressant prescriptions that are sold in this country every year,
it's staggering.
I believe it's like 30 million,
30 million people it,
let me see.
Let's see how many people are on antidepressants.
Let's just guess.
I'm saying it's about 30 million.
Yeah,
I think I remember that book.
PROZAC nation was that in the nineties that's when they started it.
It's exploded and like everyone was on Prozac squad.
It's such a huge industry.
I know.
I know a handful of people have a friend on PROZAC.
Yeah,
good guy too.
Great Guy.
Astounding.
Increase in antidepressant use by Americans like Harvard University study,
Harvard health publications from Harvard Medical School where you could just
smoke weed,
right.
People 12 and over,
increased by almost 400%
hmm.
Wow.
Okay.
Between 1988 to 1994 and then from 2005 to 2008
yeah.
That's incredible.
Holy Shit.
23% of all people on antidepressants are women in their forties and fifties no,
no,
no.
Excuse me.
23% of women in their forties and fifties are on antidepressants.
Wow.
Yeah,
but that's the one and 3% holy shit.
You're going through the change of life,
a higher percentage than any other group by age or sex.
Just stop and think about that.
23% of women in their forties and fifties are on a pill that keeps him happy.
Statistically.
That's a really good chance that our flight attendant is one of those pieces.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Look,
I had a friend that was on it and one of the things he said to me was that when
he was on it,
nothing bothered him.
He was on Zoloft and he's like,
nothing bothers me.
Nothing doesn't conveys me now that everything's fine,
Yeah.
And those kinds of people that they don't,
they don't see things coming.
They don't see.
So they're not aware that they're being weird.
I wonder what it would be interesting.
Obviously it won't happen,
but to hear what her version of that dialogue would be.
You know what I mean?
It's also kind of like,
it was great.
Talk to those guys.
So much fun.
These two guys were making wine.
We had a great conversation.
They love me.
They love my fucking anecdotes about [inaudible].
I told him the sideway story and uh,
never seen two guys have a better time.
I mean they were pretty,
they were pretty under the fucking,
one of them had two drinks.
The other one hand about fine,
maybe a total four ounces.
They were there.
They were,
they were really little glasses.
Spin glass of wine.
Yeah.
We got a couple of drunks and the fourth,
I don't know if that was what was going on if she was on antidepressants,
but I do know that she wasn't good at reading shit.
No negative.
No,
no.
You entered,
you meet people like that all the time.
Yes.
I'm related to a few,
but the,
so the question is should she have to completely or life get her shit together,
change your diet,
start exercising.
You start taking care of her.
How?
Start applying different philosophies to are alive at years of age,
you know,
and,
and advanced age or she's just take a fucking pill.
It makes her happier,
right?
I exactly,
yes.
I don't have really,
not life does not.
It's not,
it doesn't live forever.
Doesn't definitely,
there's definitely an easier path and uh,
seems like a little more resistance in another path.
But then on the processors are comparing the duck.
Yeah.
Browse with you.
Take one of these less than a third of Americans who are taking a single
antidepressant as opposed to two or more have seen a mental health professional
in the past year.
So people are just,
they're just taking the pills.
I'm fine.
Scary without any kind of supervision.
I'm a mental health professional.
Yes.
And as are you,
you guys provide mental health relief in the form of comedy.
That's true.
Well,
mental health professional from now on.
I've never done them,
but I hear what distributors of Mental Health for sure.
Yeah.
But I hear it can be helpful.
Like if we're going through some really depressing time just to kind of allow
you to get some distance to get clarity on the issue.
I mean,
I,
again,
I'm going to take a pill.
Can help you.
Yeah.
Like let's say something really tragic,
like your spouse dies and you just,
you can't even go on.
I guess it helps to give you some kind of perspective.
Well,
you know,
it's one of the best for that.
Bless you.
Yeah.
Know what the best is.
Um,
uh,
ecstasy.
Yes.
MDMS incredible for grief.
Relief for post traumatic stress.
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
For people with PTSD,
for people who've been victimized or people who have had horrible things happen
to them.
They say it's an almost immediate and really like fulfilled relief.
Like it's not just a temporary relief.
It's a relief where you gain perspective on like the like maybe you know,
I had a terrible breakup and you take ecstasy and whatever reason it allows you
to see things in a different way where you forgive and wow.
One of the big no idea.
Yeah.
It's supposed to be amazing for that.
Supposed to be amazing for stress.
Two foot soldiers and shit.
Yeah.
Soldiers coming back from the war with PTSD.
It's a huge problem.
Don Can,
you know,
put it in perspective first.
He goes,
you think about how many people are over there that experiencing things and no
one hears seeing and then they're going to come here and then they're going to
try to integrate in society and get some Shitty fucking job out and try to
forget everything they did.
Yeah.
All them killing.
Dude,
I was only,
I went to Afghanistan for two weeks,
like a couple years ago,
and just in two weeks being a spectator to a war,
just being a tourist in all of it was,
so you saw me when I came back,
I was like,
Shell shocked.
I had to,
I sat in my shrink's couch,
like balling.
Wow.
You see,
you know,
you tore the hospitals and you see little eight year old boys who fell into a
fire and they're burned.
Are you seeing the 20 year old kids who stepped on IED and they lose their limbs
or their faces are blown off?
It's terrible.
Yeah.
Really crazy.
And I didn't even,
I saw a fraction of it,
you know what I mean?
I,
yeah.
So if you're there,
give me a
tour day after day.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
war of war toward not like a tour of performing.
That's why when that guy went over and,
um,
he was,
uh,
suffering from PTSD and they will have just some murdering a bunch of people and
killed a bunch of civilians.
And they were like,
this guy had been crying for help.
Like this isn't like this guy had been talking about his PTSD trying to get out
of the arm and they sent them over there again,
he just cracked.
I mean literally reached a point where he cracked and you can only see so much
brutality so much before you lose your perspective.
You lose humanity and we don't take can,
I'm not enough.
Yeah.
And I'm not excusing what he did by any stretch of the imagination,
but I'm saying is when something like that happens,
you got to wonder like what makes a person capable of doing that?
Because they didn't do it.
But what they do,
they,
were they a psycho going in or do you make them a psycho?
Does their experiences make them a psycho?
Does the,
the,
the lack of feeling make them want to do something that shocks them?
I mean,
do they get to the point where they see so much killing and he's killed so many
people that they're not even,
they're not even aware of what's real or what's not and how medicated are they?
Or what are they medicated?
Do even know that that's your job to kill people.
That's the crazy part is they're like,
here,
you're getting a paycheck to kill people.
That's a hard thing to wrap your head around as a civilian.
US soldiers,
here we go.
That soldiers are dangerously,
dangerously over.
This is an,
um,
uh,
this article,
natural news.
Is that a real website US soldiers dangerously overmedicated with antipsychotic
drugs.
Yeah.
So that apparently there's a lot of them that they have like real issues with
war and they give them Prozac.
You need somebody,
you need to put people in there that,
um,
I'm saying like,
it's not for everybody.
You know,
like,
I think that you should almost,
there should almost be a clause where like,
you can go and be like,
I can't do this and they should let you [inaudible] NBC news heavily armed and
medicated.
That's a sudden fucking Newsweek.
Or,
uh,
NBC News Rather.
Wow.
Yeah.
Those guys,
I feel bad for them.
She'd get a card like you get into the military,
Yo,
this isn't for me.
Yeah,
you should be able to.
It's not,
here's the deal.
It's not for anybody.
It's not for anybody,
but there's some know what it is for.
It's for Psychos and people who think that it's something that it's not.
And then when they get over there,
they realize,
oh,
I'm not defending my country.
I'm working for this brutal company that doesn't give a fuck about any people.
It's comprised of people.
And yet it doesn't care about people.
It just cares about siphoning out money and distributing to a few people that
will never be over here killing people.
That's the weirdest thing at all of all.
When you look at the amount of money that gets siphoned out of war and then
inject it into the bank accounts of people that don't kill anybody,
don't risk any life,
don't risk their health for a second.
And they're living like fucking bankers.
They're living
like gangsters.
They're,
they're,
you know,
if you look at the people that are making the most money out of war,
I mean,
it's quite shocking the amount of money that you can extract and never have to
kill anybody.
Yeah.
That's why they'll always be wars forever and ever.
And I don't know about that man.
I don't know about that.
I don't think,
I don't.
I think the,
it's like,
you know,
you look at those pharmaceutical statistics and you realize that industry,
that lobby is too powerful and it's too strong for it to get defeated though.
That's why those,
those pills will be around.
There'll be new pills,
they'll be new drugs.
War is such a profitable device that I don't think you could,
I mean,
idealistically,
obviously you don't want there to be wars,
but I just don't,
I think that there's too much to be gained,
unfortunately.
I wonder America definitely,
definitely,
definitely for sure.
Yeah.
So you think there's no way to fix it?
Well,
Laura,
just so into it,
we're so in,
right?
But how can we can fix it?
How about if we ran the world?
If the world consistent of everybody in this room,
I'm pretty sure no one's going to kill anybody.
You might get mad at Brian if you fucking take some pictures,
penis over your forehead while you're sleeping or something.
But Brian would be the one that would get attacked the first,
I think.
Yeah,
he did talk to her,
but I don't think we kill him.
No,
I wouldn't murder him.
No.
I would just relegate him to some kind of job where he had no authority.
It wasn't hunting.
No hunting for Brian.
Yes.
He wasn't bringing in his food.
He was eating all your food.
You get a little annoyed like Brian,
you haven't killed one rabbit.
I sold my buzzer partying.
It was it old garden with my butt hole,
Joe.
I see it.
I see.
In your future,
would you start a society like a compound where everybody hunts their own food
and grows her own food?
Well then they're gonna come and get you that nobody wants anybody to be self
sustaining inside this country.
Who's going to,
who's going to get the government will shut it down.
You Go.
You will come in with.
Yeah,
that's so true.
I forgot about that part.
You could have a community,
but they would infiltrate it.
Government would infiltrate it.
And then they find someone who is selling mushrooms,
right.
Someone.
And then they'd come in and Boston,
the idea of someone getting a strong hold on a group of people with a different
ideology,
a nonsupportive ideology of the thing that's running the country right now.
They're not down for that.
Very true.
It's just natural.
It's natural to try to fight that off.
Oh,
sidebar.
Have you seen,
sorry,
cause I had a thought and I was,
I was driving,
we were driving to Downey like ages ago and there is a billboard for the marines
and it was like Mexican traditions,
be it be a good Mexican,
be a marine.
And you're like,
yeah,
well this is so evil.
It's sad.
Right?
Well you know I'm looking,
I read Max.
I wasn't,
I guess get to know.
Oh Wow.
That is really sneaky.
That's,
that's how you appeal to a,
a poor young dude,
right up to this ideal of manhood of perceived.
Well,
those are all those crush,
those commercials.
They all appeal to your sense of wanting to be a great,
impactful person to be an adventure,
to be,
you know,
something
to be a warrior.
Yeah.
Someone who's noble,
when there's that stand there and slide that sort of,
yeah,
it looks great though to an 18 year old boy wouldn't,
you'd be like,
fuck yeah,
that's great.
Do a 45 year old man.
We just smart enough to realize why it looks great.
Yeah.
When you see the propaganda though,
that's so guided towards a group that's not you is when you realize how much
there's propaganda,
you know,
like you don't see it as propaganda.
When you see it as an APP,
you're like,
oh,
this is a thing.
But then when you,
when it's so like geared towards another group,
you know,
like that banking commercial we saw,
Oh God,
it was ridiculous.
The girl comes home with her check and uh,
she's like speaking Spanish and English,
you know,
and it's like,
this is just so to like,
you know,
appeal to the Spanish speaking,
but it's like,
it's such a,
you know,
she's just like Spanish and English that she gets how much he's like Meta.
I got my first
Jack and then know when they're like,
she's so happy.
And then she's like,
look at my check.
He's like,
she like takes a picture.
She's like,
no,
I'm making a deposit.
And it's just like a Spanish English conversation.
And they eat tacos.
Yeah,
they're like making,
yeah.
So they're like,
just in case some white people really love Mexicans.
We'll throw a few English right here.
Yeah.
And it's just like you fucking apes.
Totally.
Any white people,
this is not for you to post to like,
this is really supposed to be effective to the person who's Latino who's like,
I don't trust banks.
And they're like this pretty cool.
So it's just for a bank.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a major bank.
The bank giving you money.
What's the mass giving you a check in the commercial?
No,
the other girls come home with from her first.
She's got her first paycheck.
Right.
So she's just like,
I got my first paycheck.
I'll say she wants to put it in that bank.
Right.
Cause it's the smart one.
Yeah.
That's the one that's going to take care of your money.
Right.
I see
what you're sitting in the bank.
Come on.
Don't be soon.
You gotta Save the money.
You don't feel it.
Don't be a fool.
Yeah.
You ever go to a neighborhood where all the signs are different languages and we
lived in a couple.
Ah,
where did you live?
Uh,
j town and then we lived in basically little El Salvador,
which is just adjacent.
You guys were in the hood for awhile.
Macarthur Park.
We are in a real shit hole.
When we got married,
we were so broke.
We heard Bang Bang's Tommy,
tell,
tell Joe you're famous.
Bang,
Bang.
One was like two in the afternoon.
I'm sitting on our living room couch,
which is basically,
you have a,
you could just look right into MacArthur park.
I'm sitting on the couch,
pants down,
jerking off to porn on my laptop and I just hear like cop,
like fucking jump on the ground.
Like I jump on the ground full boner,
like woo,
like am I in trouble?
Like it's so terrifying to be in that thought process and hear that loud.
And I just,
I pull my pants up and the first thing I do,
you're not.
So I call our Jose are whatever's,
he doesn't fucking listen to the show today is,
uh,
the building,
you know,
manager every morning.
So I call him and he's like,
what's up?
And I go,
dude,
what the fuck was that?
And he goes,
what was what?
And I go,
you didn't hear that shit?
He goes,
no,
I go sound like it was on my fucking like back,
like on my balcony.
Now I'm in the garage,
man.
I was like,
all right.
And I'm like,
this is unbelievable.
And then two minutes go by,
my phone rings and he's like,
Hey,
yeah man,
I just talked to somebody.
Uh,
somebody just got shot on the street out in front.
That's what you heard.
And then they shut down every fucking possible entrance to our street.
And what happened was a guy went up to another guy,
two in the afternoon,
broad daylight and put a 45.
Right.
Like pull that out,
shot him in the chest,
random.
Uh,
it was a gang thing and then didn't even run.
He just waited there,
waited,
waited for the cops to get arrested,
I guess.
Yeah.
There was a lot,
a lot of gang shit and that neighborhood.
Yeah.
Why did they wait?
Do they want to go back to jail?
I don't know that part,
it wasn't explained to me,
but the,
the shooting was like that,
you know,
the whole thing was that he just,
I think it was a marked guy,
like he had done something and they were like,
this is a retaliation.
Ooh,
living that gang neighborhoods.
Not Cool.
No.
What was neat though is that LAPD installed these,
uh,
like sound devices where they'd put them up on a light post or somewhere and
they could actually track exactly where the bullet was shot from within a five
mile radius.
So like,
that was Kinda cool.
Come in five mile radius.
Yeah,
I think it's,
that seems pretty big
telling you.
Yeah,
look it up.
I may be off on the,
uh,
anyway,
they could detect exactly where the bullet was coming from apparently.
All right.
Are
Our last,
uh,
one of our last nights was a celebratory night where we were room shit man.
It was a couple days after LAPD had,
there was a drunk guy on sixth street who was wielding a knife and they lit him
up like they shot him,
they shot him like fucking,
I forget it was like 13 or 22 times,
like something crazy for this drunk guy with a knife.
So they,
El Salvadoran neighborhood marched towards the Rampart division police
headquarters and it was banana.
So we're standing on the roof of our building and no shit.
There's like 20 police helicopters.
Like usually there was one or two a night every night.
But like when you see 20,
you're like,
this is martial law.
Like it was that neighborhood that night was unlike anything I've ever seen.
Wow.
It was,
they shot him for no reason.
The guy that should up for no reason.
He was,
I know.
He was like,
it's like fucking what is supposed to do.
Give them book.
Yeah.
Give him a book.
Teach him how to right.
Show
them how to wash his ass with his hand.
But I think,
no,
it was,
it's crazy.
I mean the whole thing was,
it is obviously excessive force,
but it just habit to use their guns.
Yeah.
They're excited about the reason to do it.
Some assholes got a knife.
Like this dude is just family.
Two miles,
two miles,
three miles off the Brio.
Pretty big man.
Yeah.
That's not good.
Brian Kallan was on his street and uh,
his neighbor couldn't drive his car,
couldn't figure out why he's carpet and starts you guys to Carto and they found
a bullet in the engine block and there was a shootout on a street and a stray
bullet slammed into his engine.
Jesus.
Yeah.
That's when Brian was like,
oh,
Okeydokey time to move.
Yeah.
And then a park where he used to take his daughter to play.
The guy shot a guy.
They're cool,
man.
I'm to go.
Okay.
Fuck Venice.
Great.
Venice is great though.
That's what sucks about Venice.
It's like it has all of that,
but it's also great cool restaurants and super cool,
cool little art places.
It's a,
it's a Funky,
I saw the tree slam there once.
Not that great.
I'm sorry.
Have you been to the tasting kitchen there in Venice?
No.
I don't know what that is.
A restaurant.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I've never been there.
Wait,
let's pull it to slam.
What do you like?
Less?
Poetry slams or musicals.
Poetry slams.
Okay.
Cause at least musical,
somebody likes them,
right?
You're pretending so you remember when they have,
yeah.
DEF poetry jam.
Oh yes.
That was so I stand white man in front of you on conquered on top of the
universe is my solely turtle shell.
I reach a point,
a pinnacle in my existence here and your white dominated world power will I do y
Shalah and that should suck man.
That's what that should happen with men like me did not have access to books
knowledge,
but now I thrive.
Yes,
there should be.
Definitely useful and there should be a black guy in the fucking in the rafters
with a Mike who just gets to after everyone goes,
you shit was whack too man.
Like just shits on everyday.
It's way worse than black eyes and def poetry jams.
White guys guys.
Yeah.
Poetry jams,
white guys trying to be black doing that.
Yes.
Rough.
Here's the problem with those things.
The art form itself is incredibly unsatisfying.
Like all you're doing is saying things and you're trying to be profound.
The only time anybody ever wants to hear anything like really profound like that
is from someone who is an accomplished person.
Right?
Like if Russell Simmons Simmons went up and gave a poetry slam about succeeding
in business,
right.
Then you would want to see like starting your own business and yeah,
that's Russell Simmons and it's got some poignancy to it.
But when you're some self-indulgent fucking Dick Wad and you're just talking
nonsense and strings,
which was just so bad,
so bad
shit.
And we were already told you you're good at sports.
Just keep playing sports.
What about the white people that are faster?
Oh yeah.
How are we going to see
George Watsky mean to George for George?
What about the first,
if I am right now?
Oh Christ embarrassing white guy that's got a golf shirt on.
Super friendly though.
Cause yeah,
cause he's not like,
I'm gonna be funny.
This is for those among us who got enough play through 12th grade to carry in an
upside down teaspoon for every kid with the collective romantic prowess of Steve
Article,
Richard Simmons and screech from saved by the bell.
This is the anthem Patasa Marla to God in our formative years and this poem,
it's for every high school virgin who wouldn't have had it any other.
You don't know the possibilities of a weekend until you've cracked a four pack
of juice.
Squeeze with your boys,
pumped the igs big Papa and watched an entire euro star trek the next
generation.
Never thought on virgin was working in.
I can see what Trekkie's
I feel for that boy.
That boy first is a bunch of things.
You got to tell him this person while you're breathing heavy has to stop the
deliveries.
Yeah.
The Quentin Tarantino vibe should've stopped too,
and he's definitely not going to get laid after this.
This is this thing that they do where they are in front of black people.
They,
they,
they act black.
Yeah.
There's black.
The when he talks.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yes,
yes.
Change the way he talks and it wasn't this,
it wasn't full bore,
but it was pretty obvious that she was throwing a few more,
you know what I'm saying?
So it definitely saying that will be yellow,
green juice boxes.
You know what I'm saying?
No,
I'm sorry.
But that's the thing that they do where I'm at to tell you there's a way I got
to breathe in deaf slam.
Stupid fucking breathe in between.
You're overly contrive delivery.
So contrived.
One more.
It's a girl talking about like an ex boyfriend.
I like those bow.
My heart is broken on the floor.
He said,
and you're like,
ah,
no more.
I'll put another one on.
I know.
It's an awful art form.
That's it is.
We should just talk about something else.
It's like standing up with no punchlines delivered by a guy sucks at stand up
right.
That's what it's like.
I'm so excited for the amount of hate we will collectively received for this.
It's going to be brutal,
brutal def poetry slam you have any poems?
Do you have any old poems that you know?
How dare you [inaudible] had a gun poetry slam.
The streets would be cleaner.
I don't know.
I forget how it works.
If I only had a gun,
I would just wrote something.
That's a good one.
What was really terrible?
I just think they're misguided though.
16 when I run it.
Which ones?
The people doing that that I feel like you should tell them.
You know what you want to perform and that's cool.
This thing that you're doing,
the whole thing sucks,
so just get into a different art form.
You chose the shitty thing.
You know what it's like.
It's like racing unicycles right?
UNICYCLES are fucking stupid.
Is Lame and chasing them is even dumber,
right,
because they don't work right.
They did their terrible get on a bus.
You only way,
the only reason anybody rides a unicycle is because they're a fucking attention
whore.
Me The wheels this big and he's only one of them do it.
The Guy with a paradigm,
that guy we saw the other day,
parents
just fucking walking around and sweat shorts and a six x shirt.
We talked about this guy for five minutes.
We looked at him about the winter.
We couldn't stop because we were inside the car so we could abuse him without
him hearing it.
We're just shat upon him for at least five minutes on his lonely stroll with
that,
you know,
he does just for people to go get a fucking bird snake.
People are like,
they go,
we'll do that.
Yeah.
How about people with ferrets?
Ferrets on a leash
in Miami who had the big lizard on his same thing.
That guy was smart because he was like,
oh,
you like this lizard is $20 to take a picture of.
Right.
Of course.
Which he $20 take a picture with it hoses,
but see he picked south beach.
He picked a place where there's all these tourists and they're like,
this is some shit you would never see anywhere.
This is a guy.
We came from Wisconsin.
We saw a guy,
you're not going to believe this with a lizard on his shoulder.
Have been the craziest thing I've ever seen.
I couldn't believe it.
You should've came with us and he thought he walked around like
white people walking down the street.
Silly.
Why people
does the kind of white people that you would target if you want to start a cult
too.
Exactly.
But white people bring it all back.
Scientology,
those people,
if you give them the dynamics book and started getting their email address and
send it unto Shit,
send him some pamphlets.
Yeah.
Lot people,
Clearwater,
Florida ever go down there.
So that's a scientologist stronghold.
My folks used to live there that live in Clearwater and its headquarters world
headquarters.
Yeah.
That's the spot where they all decided this is the perfect level of
intelligence.
Like the,
the average is way higher there of people that you can trick.
You know,
there's,
I'm sure there's very smart people in Clearwater,
Florida,
but there's also a lot of,
it's like serious dummies.
Yeah.
Get Him.
That's where the charlatans go,
right?
You can get them certain near Tampa,
which has allowed us,
we talked about that last swingers.
Oh yeah.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
There was a club in Ocala that no longer exists that was run by swingers,
swingers corridor.
Hey,
what the hell come on one to watch my wife from me.
Fuck no,
I'll pass.
I was with Arri once and we had a guy who drove us in Nashville and he seemed
like the most straight laced guy until the last day.
And the last day as he's driving us to the airport,
he starts talking about swinging.
He starts talking about the rules that he like.
He goes,
next time you come here,
you know,
take you a swinging club.
And Ari and I were like,
what?
What are you talking about?
And so then he starts telling us about the rules that they have.
Like,
well,
you know,
we have rules.
If I don't,
I'm not comfortable about it.
She doesn't go with the guy and uh,
you know,
she's not comfortable about it.
Uh,
I don't go with a girl or sometimes we watch each other,
but most of the time I don't like watching.
Um,
that's a lot.
Did you ever share Kristina with a cock holding,
holding,
holding
was that word?
Where does that originate from?
Shakespeare.
Yeah.
I'm sure it sounds like an old timey English sound old timey,
but I don't know if it is a kit that she like cod piece and cuckolding holding
its shape
cold in the Wikipedia.
Okay.
Historically,
it's historical,
historically referred to a husband with an adulterous wife and still often used
with this meaning and evolutionary biology.
The term call Cole does apply to males who are unwillingly unwittingly Yvette
investing parental effort in offsprings that are not genetically their own.
Wow.
That's deep.
So if your stepfather,
you're a cuckold since the 1990s,
the term has been wildly used to refer to a sexual fetish in which the fetishist
is stimulated by their committed partner choosing to have sex with someone else.
So for some men they get their rocks off that way.
But the original verb,
the original description of it,
I guess it could be a Var verb as well.
Right?
Cock holding your car holding.
Sure.
Would you ever do that?
Never.
It's okay.
First appeared in 1250.
Look at this.
1215,
a satirical and polemical poem,
the Owl and the Nightingale.
Wow.
The term was clearly regarded as an embarrassingly direct,
as embarrassingly direct as evident.
Evidence in John lied.
Gates evident in John Lied Gates,
the fall of the princess in 1440,
the late 14th century.
The term also appeared in Jeffrey clot charters.
Miller's tale.
That's interesting.
Shakespeare's poetry often reference cock holes.
Dang.
You nailed it.
Why are you married to him?
You guys get along because you're so smart.
Is that why we're blessed that we get along with your smarts,
her boots,
dude,
do it.
When I,
when I speak to you just hear like,
like chimps squeaks.
Yeah.
While there's other viewers are words for it.
There's a,
there's cuckold in Bulgarian.
Um,
and Bulgarian.
It's a,
well,
I tried it.
It doesn't even have English words start letters.
So I don't know what the fuck,
how did he say this?
P.
O,
R,
C h.
O.
C,
h e and the number four.
You know,
it's like a lower case for,
would it go to Joe?
It says you bought it.
Lethal are the one who owns one of where's horns and the act of being in fee
unfaithful is called c the number five.
Hey are caring.
They're pura literally to attach horns.
Vietnamese is a bike I'm sung by,
comes on.
It's all porn.
It's all in the word Horn.
Mollify shot.
What's that?
Massage oil price.
Whichever Ya to stop backs down.
He like Tai Chi.
They haven't Greek.
It's a totally different language is impossible.
Okay.
Number three,
backwards.
P a t a letter that doesn't exist.
Meaning the horned one?
Yeah.
Wow.
So,
uh,
okay,
cool.
What is that?
What is that fucking fetish guys would want shamed,
I'm assuming.
I have a friend who,
uh,
went to a party and the man made his wife below him.
Like he was the man washed and was giving instruction on how to blow him.
Wow.
Your friend was the one who did this.
My friend was sitting outside on the porch at a party and this woman was blowing
him while the husband was sitting next to the woman giving directions.
Wow.
And I said,
yeah.
I was like,
Whoa,
dude,
that's so intense.
Because I feel as though that might violate some trust with me.
Like I just think,
wait a minute,
I love you.
I don't want you to do that.
Well I know,
I don't think it's just dad.
I mean it was weird for my friend who was a single guy to get head from some
guy's wife while the guy saying rubbers,
Paul's brothers off like he's giving,
he's giving him direction,
like cradle,
his boss credos those Bosworth,
the shaft where the show is,
you're going to come,
he's going to come take it in your mouth.
The whole deal.
Yeah.
There's free my mouth coming Roth and gotten,
my friend was like,
oh my God,
what?
He goes,
I started,
it started out like ridiculous.
And then he goes,
but then like,
like when the guy was like giving instruction,
he goes,
it's just got really gay and weird and it was all so off.
The guy was liking it.
Of course.
Yeah.
That's the whole,
that's the pay off for him.
That's why he does it.
He likes his wife's sucking a cock.
Oh Wow.
Right in front of them.
Well I guess it's like that forbidden thing.
It's like we were talking about at the beginning about porn,
the gagging and two dicks in the ass.
Like forbidden.
You know this like you would never teach your wife on a soccer cock in front of
you rather fuck until she goes sucking cock and I'm going to show it what to do.
Yeah,
I'm just pitching it to do,
he's such a curve with where those poles.
Oh rose bowl is dirty bitch.
Imagine what,
what the fuck that would be like no Jesus.
No,
but this is people's lives,
right?
Where's this is your shit
bond between husband and wife and I cannot not.
We'll just cut the old growth now with the cup holds are swingers.
No,
no.
You've seen,
cause I'm sure you've been like,
I've had couples,
they're always never attractive come up to you and they're like,
what's up?
Like we're going to go out and have a good time.
Do you want to join us?
And you feel that like,
you know that invitation to come out with us,
it'd be a great time.
We're gonna hit this crazy club and like check out my wife's tits and like,
you know,
they're putting it out there that you know,
you can have you come party with us.
Weird Shit.
We've been together now for almost eight years and to the thought of being naked
with somebody different is so crazy to me.
You haven't seen Brian naked.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
You don't want that and that no dairy or days or a day.
You turn your back on that wonderful opportunity.
Hey Joe,
can I ask you?
Oh,
would you rather we came up with it when you went in the car?
This one's just for you.
Okay.
What'd you rather for an entire year all you can eat all,
you can eat his hot dogs from seven 11 and Gatorade.
Okay.
That's one option.
Or wait and you can't,
oh,
and you cannot exercise,
but you must eat hot dogs and get right or the other option no.
Or you can't eat or you can't exercise.
That's it.
Right.
So either you're not allowed to exercise,
but you can eat what you want.
Or the other one is eating hot dogs and Gatorade,
but you can still exercise.
Hmm.
That's a good question.
Thank you.
So here's the thing you have to consider,
right?
So you're going to have to go with the no exercise,
no exercise and eat whatever you want.
Yeah,
yeah.
I would eat healthy and not exercise,
but I would do things that would be like exercise.
I'd be like,
well,
I'm going to just work in a fucking sandbag yard now.
Oh,
right.
I would say,
hey man,
can I,
uh,
can I work here for four hours a week and then four days a week that's crafted.
Oh,
to come in for an hour and just work for like 10 bucks an hour,
throwing sandbags around.
I would just do it really gangster.
Okay.
What Liz?
Revise this.
What if you're just,
you can't do that.
That's what I would do though.
I would,
I would be too smart for you.
You have to,
it will just take a job.
That would take a hard labor job.
You have to lay in bed,
but you could do,
but you could do talks.
You would do all the exercise that you want with your hot dogs and you or it.
Every day,
every meal I need more new.
Your body would break down.
How would you,
yeah.
Your body would break down.
You would have a real issue.
If you were just eating hot dogs and Gatorade and and trying to exercise,
you wouldn't have the nutrients to sustain any sort of strenuous exercise.
Can someone please make a exercise video of just hot dog?
Do you know why?
We'd probably die of scurvy.
We'd say we did it because one of our friends stayed at our house one time for
like three days and he ate just hot dogs and gator.
Listen,
man,
ever since I cut gluten out of my diet,
I Miss Pasta,
but they have great gluten free pasta.
You know what?
I really fucking miss a hot dog with a bone,
a steamy bond with some mustard and sauerkraut.
I missed that gummy shitty been,
yeah,
I miss Italian bread to browers.
You still eat,
you just can't eat.
The eyebrow brought worst.
I just don't eat the bun but a hot dogs,
no miss that to me.
What is this?
Gluten free so that means what component?
I don't need any bread and eat pasta.
I don't eat anything that has flour in it.
I've been doing it for about four months,
maybe five months.
What I've noticed like right away when I first started doing it is how when I,
when I have meals after meals,
I'm not tired anymore.
Like I used to get tired.
I would eat a meal.
I'd be like,
oh,
it hit that fucking lawn dart of just like exhaustion.
Now I can eat a giant steak and I never get there.
Never get there.
I can eat potatoes and I never get there.
There's something about gluten,
about eating pasta.
It never did anything bad to me.
Like I don't have CELIAC's disease.
It.
It was not something that made me fat,
but when I quit eating pasta and bread,
I definitely lost body fat quickly.
I noticed that on my face,
like my face was like less puffy.
My ring starting to fit in my finger,
different sweater and I weigh almost the same.
Like I'm like,
oh maybe I lost a few pounds,
like three or four pounds or something like that.
But it seems like whatever the puffiness was,
it's like my puffiness number went down cause I was eating pasta and bread every
meal.
She's love it.
Gluten free bread.
Yes.
It's terrible.
It's just like fucking cardboard.
Actually Udis has some pretty decent gluten free bread,
but it's just simply not as good as gluten bread.
It's just not cause regular bread.
You know,
he took regular bed and you machine and turn into a ball and that ball becomes
like paste.
Yeah,
it's,
it's like eating gum and there's no nutritional value in that bread.
The problem,
no sugar.
Doesn't it convert to sugar on your balcony or something?
Yeah,
it tastes awesome.
Your body doesn't want it at all.
Your body doesn't like it,
your body doesn't perform as good.
When I started doing,
when I quit it,
my endurance went up.
Um,
my body started feeling better.
My back started feeling better.
Like that's what the advice that I got from a physical therapist.
She told me that she has great results in people with back injuries telling them
to quit gluten that did decrease inflammation of gluten actually decreases the
size of their bulging discs.
I was like,
dad,
it's fucking nuts.
She's like,
well it makes sense because like knee injuries like a lot of times like the
swelling and the inflammation of knee injuries,
you can reduce that as well.
Yeah,
I can see that.
Fucking gluten.
Don't they tell you just eat fruits and vegetables and meats anyways,
like keep it living now.
Shouldn't even need that much fruit.
You should let it limit the amount of fruit and less except like after working
out as good or while you're working out in the middle of doing things.
We are burning off a lot of calories.
Fruit's good,
but you should limit,
definitely limit the amount of juice you drink because we need to drink fruit
juice.
It's like straight sugar does have fiber in it.
You know when you eat an apple,
you're getting fiber orange,
you're getting fiber and you're getting suites where he's just drink Gatorade,
like all every hot
dogs.
But what would you do,
you guys do?
Would you take the no exercise or what's your take Gatorade?
I,
I would,
I can't,
cause I'm,
I'm very particular with eating actually.
Do Watch what I eat.
I couldn't eat it because you feel like shit when you eat hot dogs and Gatorade
you feel yeah,
it's not good.
No.
And you can get by without exercising if you watch your diet properly.
Yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
I can't,
I can't eat like
you could definitely get away with being okay.
No.
Yeah.
Not Fantastic.
But at least you can keep your weight down somewhat.
I just,
I dunno,
the older I get,
the harder it is to eat.
Like shit,
I can't even do it now.
Well,
plus you would,
I enjoy eating.
That's another part of the problem.
Yeah.
I like good food.
I like food.
That tastes good.
Yeah.
Hotdogs and fucking,
it would drive me nuts after awhile.
You're crazy.
All right.
This podcast is basically it over.
I want you guys to subscribe to your mom's house.
It's on iTunes.
It's fucking hilarious.
It's Tom and Christina's podcast and they can find you guys online.
Do you guys have a podcast,
a website,
your mom's house,
podcast.com uh,
Thompson,
goroka.com [inaudible] dot com Christina comedy outcome.
It's Christina.
No,
you don't know.
Visits Kia and trust people negative too.
Fucking stupid.
And uh,
upcoming dates.
You guys got any upcoming?
Yes.
Big One.
Uh,
November 1st and second.
I'm running my hour in La at flappers in Burbank.
And you can go to my site and get it a Thompson [inaudible] dot com my special
is November 9th in Minneapolis.
You can get free tickets at Thomson [inaudible] Dot Com Pam Craig,
Christina and I are doing your mom's house live November 22nd at the Ice House
and December 5th in San Diego at the American comedy company.
Good.
Google Mowgli San Diego
this weekend at the Mad House Comedy Club,
October 25th through 27th and then in Hartford at the funny bone.
November 14th,
three seven.
Boom.
Sweet Jesus.
We're uh,
this podcast is brought to you by Squarespace.
Use the Code Joe and the number ten one word Joe 10.
Save 10% off your first purchase on new accounts.
Um,
that's squarespace.com the number Joe 10 were also brought to you by stamps.com
for your super awesome extra sweet deal.
Use The code word J,
r e and get your $110 bonus offer,
which includes a digital scale and up to $55 of free postage.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] Dot Com that's o.N ,
n.
I.
T.
You use the code named Brogan and save 10% off any of the supplements.
We'll be back tomorrow with the one and only Eddie Bravo to break down this past
weekend's UFC that Tommy buns was ringside for
on believable.
Tune in for that shit.
Those fights were incredible.
The greatest night of fights in the history.
Incredible.
Diego Sanchez fight was incredible.
And the main event,
um,
uh,
Dosantos for Alaska,
it was just mind blowing.
Crazy shit.
All right.
We love you guys.
We'll see you tomorrow.
Big
Kiss.
Ciao.